nombreuses années on essaye de le
dénoncer de se faire entendre
on est arrivé une limite on n'a pas de
réponse à nos questionnements à nos
revendications on a quatre
revendications principales
c'est l'augmentation des effectifs la
baisse de la sur-sollicitation en fait
des missions sapeurs pompiers
aujourd'hui les pompiers interviennent
sur un bon nombre de missions du au
désengagement des services de l'état que
ce soit les services de police parce que
tout ce qui y voient public on engage
les sapeurs pompiers ou alors des
transporteurs de sanitaires décennies
pour les samu en fait quelqu'un
transport de personnes malades
ce n'est pas une mission sapeurs
pompiers et pompiers doivent intervenir
que sur l'urgence les gens qui sont en
détresse vitale un arrêt cardiaque par
exemple
donc en fait toute cette charge
opérationnelle on peut pas la réaliser
aujourd'hui avec l'effectif que l'on a
donc vraiment on n'a pas de
revendication salariale à part cette
augmentation de la limite est de feu qui
correspond à la prime de risque on
considère que c'est légitime d'avoir
l'équivalent à ce qu'ils ont les autres
professions à risques comme les
policiers ensuite on a eu nos
revendications qui portent sur notre
retraite
on est sur une catégorie active donc on
a encore plein de points faire
concrétiser en fait sur ce que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui le régime existant
et soit on nous prévoit sur la réforme
et les violences sur les
sapeurs-pompiers les agressions on veut
qu'ils aient réellement une prise de
conscience de la part de nos gouvernants
pour qu'on soit protégée en intervention
et qu'on puisse intervenir avant d'aller
d'être engagé ça se passe en appel en
arrivant on ne doit pas se retrouver
dans une situation à prendre des coups
de couteau ou où tout ça on a une
proposition que nous avons rejeté que
nous convient pas le ministre
avec les employeurs quand qui sont les
présidents des conseils départementaux
et les responsables de mairie et de
grosses mairie et de pci nous propose
une augmentation à 5% quand nous on
demande 20 6% par an quand nous
demandent une augmentation à 9 pourtant
de latran dignité de feu 5% étalée sur
trois ans avec la libre appréciation
appréciation de nos employeurs donc en
fait on va avoir des pompiers dans un
département qui pourrait avoir une
augmentation de 6 % d'autres pompiers
par aucune augmentation parce que les
finances ne le permettrait pas donc ça
ne s'est pas entendable on peut pas
accepter
justement avec ce système de retraite
qui arrive derrière qui sera liée à la
rémunération peut pas accepter les
différences de traitement déjà
qu'aujourd'hui on dénonce des
différences de distribution de secours
en fonction des territoires
aujourd'hui la plupart de nos
revendications c'est de faire en sorte
que le français comprennent que le
service public de secours n'est plus en
capacité d'absorber toutes les missions
aujourd'hui les sapeurs pompiers ne sont
pas satisfait du des éléments qui nous
sommes qui sont avancés tout simplement
parce que nous partons sur un principe
de répartition toute la population sauf
que ce principe même conduire à ce que
les les travailleurs viendront à
capitaliser tout simplement parce que
les montants ne se rendent plus
suffisant même si on est sur un principe
de répartition et d'achat de points
puisque il s'agit bien d'une dispositif
universel où on doit se porter acquéreur
de points sur toute la carrière pour
autant est-ce que les points qui seront
achetés par le travailleur mais en même
temps par par l'employeur suffiront à
maintenir un niveau de conscience
suffisante pour que l'on puisse
continuer à vivre après avoir travaillé
tant d'années nous espérons les nos
collègues sont très motivés vont
exprimer leur mécontentement face à des
situations qui aujourd'hui est
exceptionnel puisque c'est la première
fois que nous connaissons
une durée aussi importante en termes
d'engagements sur un mouvement social
voilà donc
deux pompiers que vous venez d'entendre
étaient présents sur ce plateau ce matin
concernant donc cette manifestation des
pompiers aujourd'hui la deuxième en
moins de quatre mois ils sont en train
d'arriver
du côté de la place de la nation on
aperçoit un beau coup de fumigènes on
aperçoit beaucoup de fumée par moments
des scènes un petit peu confuses comme
ici où on voit un manifestant jeter
un fumigène un petit peu un petit peu
au-delà de part hier de protection
situation très confuse
donc à à paris on le rappelle il ya eu
tout à l'heure une partie du boulevard
périphérique parisien qui a été bloquée
puis également une scène assez tendue
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
pompiers ont par un direct pour
retrouver l'un d'eux
nous correspond dans nos envoyés
spéciaux s'agit de guillemin rossi et
sur les dernières minutes forte de cette
tension dans cette manifestation
[Musique]
lim un rossi ou est-ce que vous vous
situez exactement et quels sont les
quelle est l'ambiance je me situe tout
près tout près de la place de la nation
là où les la fin du cortège est en train
d'arriver donc plusieurs milliers de
pompiers qui sont en train de se diriger
vers cette place pour l'instant dans une
ambiance calme ici en tout cas cette fin
de cortège ici ça ça se déplace
lentement mais sûrement et dans le calme
vers la place de la nation beaucoup de
pétarades quand même vous l'avez vous
l'avez entendu beaucoup de fumigènes
mais pas de débordements en tous cas
pour le moment rien qui puisse faire
penser à ce qu'ils avaient vécu les
pompiers lors de la dernière
manifestation en octobre dernier où il y
avait eu voilà je vous le rappelle est
vous l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs vous même
plusieurs blessés donc pour l'instant
voilà le cortège est en train d'arriver
ils devraient être les derniers pompiers
devraient arriver d'ici dire que
quelques dizaines de minutes peut-être
avant qui sait une dispersion peut-être
va seront ils un petit peu plus
longtemps sur place de la nation en tout
cas pendant la suite est encore
incertaine mais pour le moment tout se
déroule normalement en tout cas à cet
endroit précis du collège justement guy
marrot si vous venez d'évoquer la
dispersion bientôt évidemment tous les
pompiers qui manifeste mon arrivée sur
cette place
la nation qu'elle va être ensuite leur
objectif rester le plus longtemps
possible
est ce qu'il y à une horaire de prévu
pour la dispersion et comment est-ce que
cela va se passer selon vous est ce que
vous avez pu discuter avec certains
pompiers autour de vous alors pas encore
comme je voulais dire il n'ya pas encore
d'aurea exact exact de connu tout ce
qu'on sait c'est pour l'instant ils sont
installés bien installé ensuite tout va
dépendre en réalité de comment la
gestion va se faire sur place de comment
est-ce que les forces de l'ordre bien
plus pour encadrer en fait cette fin de
manifestation et comment tout cela va se
trouver dans son n ya pas de
notification immédiate de prévu on
à la suite
les
et pour un quart d'heure j'espérais que
vous apportez un pécule d'incarnation
les campings surface merci guimard aussi
en direct donc de cette manifestation
des sapeurs pompiers
on le rappelle que les pompiers
professionnels représentent 16% des 247
mille pompiers en france les autres
étant volontaire ou aux militaires donc
une ambiance pour le moment qui se passe
bien malgré tout à l'heure une scène de
tensions entre certains pompiers les
forces de l'ordre au départ du cortège
du côté de la place de la république le
cortège qui est en train d'arriver du
côté de la place de la nation sont donc
des sifflets des sirènes avec des
fumigènes multicolores attention ici on
voit ici des images de deux canons à eau
sur des manifestants qui sont protégés
par par des barricades
image assez assez violente
convient donc en direct sur l'antenne
d'arte et france avec des manifestants
vêtus de noir visage masqué
alors est ce que ce sont des pompiers ou
plutôt des black box difficile de le
savoir
en tous les cas à les forces de l'ordre
qui ont fait usage de canons à eau
à l'instant et tout de suite un retour
en images sur les dernières minutes de
fortes tensions dans cette manifestation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
à gauche
ouais
[Musique]
c
m
[Applaudissements]
voilà on vient de vivre des images
fortes depuis le début de cet après midi
les pompiers qui sont donc en colère
deuxième journée de mobilisation
nationale pour les pompiers
professionnels venus de toute la france
dans la capitale on a perçu tout à
l'heure des canons à eau projetée par
les forces de l'ordre les pompiers qui
sont arrivés du côté de la place de la
nation 1.2
en finale de ce cortège on peut
retrouver en direct mohamud et laure
présente au sein de ce cortège qui suit
donc ces défis liés depuis le début de
cet après midi on ait hammou dès leur
première question rassurez-nous sur
votre état de santé je crois que vous
avez reçu un pétard c'est bien ça
oui exactement
les jouets c'est bon tiercé
c'est compliqué de contre manifestation
puisque les pompiers sont tous assez
bien et vit avec leurs uniformes noirs
casques leurs boutiques et les pédales
un petit pont du casse et imprévisible
ça va ou est-ce qu'ils atterrissent et
donc ça a été très compliqué en tout cas
là on se porte très bien on est à la
place de la lâchant les plusieurs
affiches indiquaient ils ont été très
nombreux à répondre présents ils nous
viennent de toute la france et justement
je suis avec nathalie saint malo bonjour
à vous pourquoi est ce que c'est
important pour vous aujourd'hui de
manifester alors aujourd'hui on voit que
tous les pompiers de france sur la
présence aujourd'hui la première
indication sera tout d'abord comme
beaucoup de français qui ne peuvent
justement être pas la présence par
rapport au privé ou public
par rapport aux retraites c'est à dire
que sapeur-pompier aujourd'hui ne peut
pas partir à 59 en retraite c'est pas
possible on a un métier qui est pénible
qui est difficile on transfère la nuit
ont subi des agressions
voilà le métier se complique au
la france va mal tout compliqué
aujourd'hui et on le voit dans plein de
profession même plein de vos mails voilà
notre premier rang des revendications la
deuxième revendication c'est que
aujourd'hui le centre pompiers de france
n'est pas reconnu comme un sapeur
pompier qui est un métier à risque
d'accord donc il y adeux les gendarmes
la police les égoutiers voilà beaucoup
de quelques excusez moi quelques
professions du reconnue à risque
malheureusement nous on les portiers ce
qu'ils aimeront de le dire mais le
maitien ce pas fonctionner sans risque
il est où le problème
point d'interrogation voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous sommes aussi nombreux
dans les rues aujourd'hui à paris mais
ici il ya cette prime de fin qui veulent
qu'elle augmente c'est ça justement
cette prime de feu est lié par rapport
au métier à risque si on est reconnus
métier à risques voilà la prime de feu
et ten dexia rapporte 100
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
aussi nombreux à paris on sait que les
pompiers il existe que leur vie de tous
les jours pour se lever pour sauver les
français
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont les difficultés
les conditions vous avez à subir tous
les jours pour des gens landais qui
connaissent pas forcé [ __ ] et d'autre
mais petit doit être métier alors la
difficulté de notre métier c'est bien
sûr tout d'abord nous travaillons la
nuit nous travaillons dans des
conditions parfois difficiles
c'est à dire qu'à toutes les heures de
la nuit il faut se lever
nous subissons des agressions c'est un
métier qui reste quand même pénible
voilà non non non non notre pénibilité
il ya eu des discussions avec le
ministre de l'intérieur et vous ont pas
convaincus absolument pas des
discussions effectivement au lieu mais
alors il reste complètement il nous
écoute pas il n'y a rien du tout pour
les sans rien est acquis il ya dans son
élément
aucune négociation qui sont acquises
vous dit qu'il ya un mutisme justement
la part du gouvernement on ne vous
écoute pas assez qu'est ce que cela
traduit selon vous mais satrapi que
comme madame beaucoup beaucoup après ce
pratiquement tous les métiers voilà tout
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui en france eh
ben ça traduit que la france va très
très mal
et qu'aujourd'hui entre gros malaise en
france voilà ce que ça traduit et que ça
va devenir je pense très difficile de
vivre en france pour en france et
l'andorre moyens comme nous
sapeurs-pompiers lambda une catégorie
moyenne et que vous avez fait trajet 200
maillots pour venir ici complètement
voilà comment comme les gens du sud du
nord de de l'est toute la france
aujourd'hui tous les pompiers sont
réunis ici et on est en nombre
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est important
et j'espère qu'on va être entendu
reconnu le gouvernement parce que ça
devienne très compliqué merci beaucoup à
vous pour ce témoignage merci et bon
courage à vous vous l'avez entendu
grégory des sapeurs-pompiers qui sont
très mobilisés on va faire un petit peu
un tour ensemble pour convoyer un petit
peu à l'ambiance qui a
la place de la nation c'est lors de la
dispersion donc il ya un petit pot monde
qu'il y avait tout à l'heure à essayer
d'avancer
pour montrer comment ça se passe
sur place et et vous l'entendez sans
doute grégory c'est extrêmement
compliqué de 200 tentes puisqu'il y
avait à des pétards qui sont lancés tout
toute l'ailé les dix voire 30 secondes
donc voilà vous avez plusieurs camions
canaux de syndicaux de syndicats pardon
qui sont ici il ya ce camion de la cgt
il y avait également force ouvrière il y
avait d'autres syndicats de pompiers qui
étaient également présents ici
quand je vous disais c'est un petit peu
compliqué de le faire c'est direct
puisque plusieurs pétards sont lancés en
viande en éviter un juste ici à
l'instant donc je vous le disais il ya
eu plusieurs réunions avec le
gouvernement de l'intersyndicale des
sapeurs pompiers qui vraisemblablement
n'ont pas convaincu en tout cas ces
pompiers et en marge de cette
manifestation avait également un
rendez-vous qui est attendu un rendez
vous avec heures toujours
ministère devant le ministre de
l'intérieur
je vous coupe la mode alors je me
permets de vous couper parce qu'on a des
images en direct du côté de la place de
la nation vers le boulevard périphérique
puisqu'on voit des manifestants ça
s'anime un petit peu des manifestants
qui tentent de forcer des débats
repositionner cours de vincennes pour
les empêcher d'accéder aux périphériques
les forces de l'ordre qui utilisent le
le canon à eau pour mettre fin aux
exactions selon la préfecture de police
de paris
des images un petit peu confuse que nous
sommes en train de vivre avec également
des jets de bombes lacrymogènes
également pour tenter de disperser les
manifestants
on peut partir également rejoindre notre
autre reporter sur place il s'agit de
guimard aussi dit mince que vous nous
entendez est ce que vous êtes à
proximité de de ce point névralgique
j'ai envie de dire là où des
manifestants tentent de forcer des bars
pour se rendre sur le boulevard
périphérique du côté de la porte de
vincennes
eh bien écoutez nous sommes pile de
l'autre côté en réalité là où nous
sommes
les manifestants les pompiers continuent
d'arriver se sont posés sur ce côté de
la place de la nation en effet d'autres
de l'autre côté de la place de la nation
certains pompiers en effet on décida d
un petit peu plus loin on a commencé à
discuter un petit peu avec certains qui
sapera donc en effet s'ils vont rester
encore sûr c'est sur cette place ou
s'ils vont se disperser tout va dépendre
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
de la gestion en fait par les forces de
l'ordre et également de l'avis de ces
pompiers qui ont été ou pas convaincu
par les différentes réunions qui ont
lieu aujourd'hui avec l'intersyndicale
au ministère de l'intérieur avec la
ministre de tutelle
et donc je suis justement avec avec
allemande pompiers qui est qui
manifestent manifeste taquet sur cette
place de la nation alors qu'est ce que
vous espérez exactement est ce que vous
pensez obtenir surtout de la part de
votre ministre alors nous ce qu'on
voudrait c'est la reconnaissance vient
risque un statut pour les sapeurs
pompiers volontaires
quand vous voyez que là on est en train
de se battre pour un repos pour l'europe
ou de sécurité ou en fin de compte si
vous regardez on doit travailler 12
heures par rapport à la loi européenne
mais on applique les lois en fait en
fonction du gouvernement comme ça les
arrange et c'est votre problème en fait
c'est à dire que nous on n'est pas
reconnu comme métier à risque au niveau
salaire on est des fois payer moins cher
qu'un car ils peur qu'un éboueur et
c'est ça qui on n'a rien contre eux au
contraire ils le méritent leur salaire
mais nous on est prêt à risquer notre
vie pour tout le monde pour tout le
monde même pour les gens qui nous
agressent quand on se fait agresser dans
la rue quand on se fait agresser sur
l'intervention si ces gens là étaient
prises dans un peu on serait même prêt à
donner notre vie pour eux et c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'on veut me expliquer
tout ça au jour et le problème c'est
qu'on n'est pas entendue donc on cherche
en fait absolument avant d'ouvrir un
politique qui un jour commence à nous
défendre
qui reconnaît ce spécialiste qui nous
prennent en compte parce que c'est tous
les gouvernements successifs depuis des
années depuis un peu plus de 30 ans
keane ou négligents fait sauf que en ou
négligents nous il néglige aussi la
population est-ce que vous pensez que
vous allez être entendue est ce que vous
pensez vous aller à va avoir cette
fameuse ce hausses de primes du peu que
vous demandez est-ce que vous pensez que
vous allez avoir les renforts les
effectifs supplémentaires que vous
demandez par exemple alors par exemple
par rapport aux effectifs qui a des
départements qui ont embauché parce que
les politiques qui tiennent les
départements en fin de compte
oui embauche parce qu'ils ne savent ils
en sont conscients qu'il ya une pénurie
de pompiers on avait pu empocher
pompiers volontaires donc c'est qu'à un
moment et le problème est vraiment grave
quoi parce que nous on est une minorité
au niveau professionnel mais les
pompiers volontaires un pompier
volontaire qui commence sa carrière la
première année tous ces jours de congé
qui soit dans le privé ou dans le public
il fallait passer en formation et il
fera pas avec sa famille donc c'est très
compliqué de recruter et à savoir
qu'avant un pompier volontaire quand il
rentrait vente et pour quinze ou vingt
ans maintenant sans moyens tôt cinq et
sept ans et on les forme est là on est
en train de se trouver une solution par
exemple nous prouverons des propositions
pour conformer pompiers au secourisme et
donc les quand ils resteront comme le
coup la formation airbus
pour l'instant dit ils veulent modifier
comme ça mais on espère être entendue
mais pour l'instant tout le monde ne
veut personne nous écoutent quoi en
fonction des annonces ce qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant
j'ai discuté avec certains de vos
collègues qui certains me disais bon on
va pas tarder à se disperser de toute
façon avec les le nom des forces de
l'ordre présents ça va pas être possible
et d'autres qui a semblé un peu plus
motivés quand même alors pas forcément
en découdre en tout cas rester coûte que
coûte pour vous continuer à se faire
entendre alors le problème par exemple
tout à l'heure on était avec les
gendarmes les gendarmes mobiles très
bien passé aussi un dialogue on se
côtoie tout ça et avec les crs c'est eux
qui nous ont chargés
donc en fait est un rapport qu elles ont
relativement différent fait entre la crs
la police et les gendarmes
donc on attend de voir on sait pas
comment ça va évoluer a priori il ya
quand même beaucoup de monde au tennis
feu je pense que les gens aient eu des
blessés on a eu un blessé là que tout à
l'heure on n'est pas là pour se faire
blesser quoi on est juste là pour se
faire entendre et malheureusement on
nous écoute pas quoi et les politiques
mettent la pression pour pas que nos
véhicules soient attaqués au plan des
stein façon les abîmes pas nos véhicules
on met juste la peinture pour va
comprendre que nous aussi on appelle au
secours entre guillemets c'est vite la
vie aussi la population c'est ça notre
problème et je sais pas comment on va
s'en sortir parce que pour l'instant
tout le monde tout le monde le fait la
sourde oreille
donc on espère que notre ministre se
réveille à un moment un autre et
viennent viennent vers nous et bien nous
écouter
la semaine dernière il y avait une rave
une réunion avec les syndicats la
réunion était annulé les syndicats tempo
courant donc le respect pour nous je
sais pas si on a vraiment par la
population c'est sûr parce que
régulièrement s'applaudir on ouvre une
classe naissante en appel pour le voir
ici mais dans nos départements
respectifs c'est très compliqué en fait
si vous voulez en tant que fonctionnaire
on a des droits et des devoirs belle la
maintenance doit on se bat pour nos
droits
alors que les devoirs on le fait au
quotidien mais nos droits on ne le
respecte plus c'est ça notre problème
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions on vous l'avez entendu un
les pompiers ici sont en colère ils ont
quand même énormément de revendications
beaucoup de frustration parce que vous
l'avez entendu ça fait cela fait des
années il y avait déjà eu un épisode en
2003 où on avait discuté il avait été
question de ce fameux statut des
pompiers alors il y avait
le on avait évoqué la possibilité de
qualifier de métier dangereux mais pas
de métier à risques toutes ces questions
sont depuis très longtemps et elle
ressurgit existe depuis très longtemps
et re surprise aujourd'hui quant à la
suite de cette manifestation et bien
vous l'avez entendu tout va dépendre
réalité des annonces de ce que vont
penser les pompiers de ces annonces et
puis surtout de leur colère et de leur
motivation aller jusqu'au bout a
continué à se faire entendre en tout cas
encore ici à ce point en ce point précis
de la place de la nation pour l'instant
pas de débordements seulement des des
pétarades seulement des fumigènes de la
musique et c'est à peu près tout en
revanche et vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
répéter dans d'autres points il y a eu
lieu il y a eu également tout au long du
cortège
ddd point un peu de tension avec avec
les forces de l'ordre avec les crs
donc tout ça peut se terminer dans le
calme comme tout ça peut se terminer
avec des affrontements
de nouveaux affrontements comme cela
s'était bien passé je vous le rappelle
en fin d'année dernière merci guy marrot
cyr en direct donc de la place de la
nation effectivement première
mobilisation c'était au mois d'octobre
dernier c'est donc la deuxième
manifestation des pompiers en l'espace
de quelques mois simplement de l'autre
côté doux se situe à guy moreau si on le
voit du côté de la porte de vincennes
j'envoie des pompiers qui sont présents
face à des barrières et me anti-émeutes
encore été installées pour bloquer leur
progression
on a vu tout à l'heure des pots pied en
tenue tenté d enfoncer les forces de
l'ordre qui ont répliqué avec des
grenades de désencerclement avec des
canons à eau également et concernant le
boulevard périphérique à noter un tout à
l'heure bien une tentative de partir sur
vos périphériques a été dénoncé par
[Musique]
la préfecture de police de paris qui
dément ce site un ennemi cible blocage
sur ce plateau christophe crépin vient
de nous rejoindre bonjour vous êtes
porte parole du syndicat france police
policiers en colère on a entendu au
micro de jean marc aussi à lens quand un
pompier évoqué le chiffre d'un blessé
est-ce que vous avez des chiffres
concernant les éventuels ne s'agit pas
de sic de chiffres qui ont été
communiqués par la préfecture je sais
que j'ai de mes collègues qui seront
baissées je sais qu'il y a eu un blessé
léger
du côté des pompiers mais je vous le
dire que bassam à parité syndicale
france police policiers en colère nous
sommes avec les peaux les pompiers qui
ont des doléances qui nous sont pour
nous légitime à la star du fait que les
violences où nous avons toujours dénoncé
aujourd'hui les instructions de la
préfecture de police sont très claires
il faut vraiment qu'il n'y ait vraiment
enfin de possibilité d'avoir deux casses
ou quoi que ce soit c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette manifestation est
encadrée d'une manière très serrée des
dispositifs policiers justement
aujourd'hui comment quel est le
dispositif policier justement juger des
gendarmes mobiles j'ai des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité et aussi des
dispositifs de la préfecture de police
qui sont tout au long je vous avoue des
deux chiffres comme ça parce que en fait
c'est évolutif en fait on avait des gens
qui sont tout le long de la
manifestation
là on va arriver sur la fin de cortège
sur le fait qu'ils veuillent pietri sur
le périphérique
je pense que c'est inconcevable parce
que ils exposent eux mêmes leur vie et
ils s'exposent à des complications assez
conséquente
concernant leurs doléances pour nous
elles sont louables mais faut pas
oublier une chose pour vos
téléspectateurs c'est que en fait les
pompiers travaillent sous instruction du
ministre de l'intérieur comme la police
nous on n'est pas du tout opposée aux
pompiers au contraire on apprécie
beaucoup de travailler main dans la main
et là aujourd'hui la préfecture de
police ou donne des instructions qui
sont très clairs et qu'ils sont
justement de ne pas de ne pas laisser à
la porte ouverte à quelques les actions
que ce soir
dont celle que nous sommes en train de
voir à l'image avec des politiques qui
essayaient de pénétrer sur le boulevard
périphérique comme ça c'est inconséquent
parce que déjà il faut comprendre une
chose qu'on adule sens du portugal et
pompiers qui sont des pompiers comme moi
des professionnels qui sont tous les
jours à la caserne de champerret ou fait
c'est 100 des 200 qui râlent 7000
pompiers en france voilà mes élans
tolérance de ce sont des gens qui sont
dans la société civile important et qui
revêtent l'uniforme pour pouvoir porter
assistance à nos citoyens donc leurs
doléances pour nous sauce aux sons des
doléances qui sont louables revêtent
l'uniforme venez de dire une histoire
n'est pas tout le temps mais qui sont
annulés à un certain un certain moment
où par exemple vous avez un accident de
voie publique
hop ils quittent leur travail ils
mettent leurs uniformes ils viennent
porter assistance
vous avez un feu ces séjours de choses
mais l'uniforme d'habitude uniforme
auquel et certains ont mis le feu
tout à l'heure pour justement dénoncer
symboliquement voyez en fait rire on a
quand même une grosse fracture sociale
dans notre pays il serait temps
peut-être que le gouvernement se rendre
compte que des métiers qui sont des
métiers de sûreté de sécurité et
d'assistance auprès du public ne sont
pas tout à fait heureux en fait il ya
peut-être une réponse à apporter
alors l'occasion des retraites fait que
maintenant tous les corps sont en
discordance par rapport au gouvernement
le fait de voir des images comme celles
ci en direct ça vous fait quoi
ça fait mal au coeur c'est parce que
nous travaillons main dans la main avec
les pompiers la police nationale les
pompiers on a le même on a le ministère
de l'intérieur qui nous dirigent en fait
et nous travaillons vraiment mal main
dans la main et quand il nous parle que
des pompiers sont agressés par coty
scott et interviennent nous on vit ça au
quotidien ou d'aujourd'hui on obligé
d'escorter les camions de pompiers pour
qu'ils puissent rentrer dans certains
endroits on a quand même une société qui
a complètement évolué tout ce qui
représente la société le pouvoir enfin
le l'autorité est mis en péril
je vous propose christophe crépin de on
voulait repartir du côté de monnaie à
moudre pour prendre le pouls sur place
de cette manifestation a priori on va
devoir patienter un petit peu pour
retrouver mona amoud et lors il ya
également un guillemin rossi qui est sur
place donc dispositif important du côté
d'arte et france pour suivre cette cette
mobilisation des pompiers plusieurs
milliers d'entre eux qui défilent donc
de nouveau aujourd'hui pour dénoncer le
manque d'effectifs et de reconnaissance
de leur pro de leur profession ils
réclament également des garanties pour
leur retraite d'ailleurs christophe
crépin alors qu'on est toujours en train
de voir ces images du côté de la place
de la nation vers le boulevard
périphérique on est à la porte de
vincennes plus précisément
[Musique]
et manifeste forcément contre la réforme
des retraites également alors que demain
il y à une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation nationale contre la réforme
des retraites à l'appel d'une
intersyndicale
qu'est ce qui va se passer demain j'ai
envie de dire 24 heures après ce qui se
passe maintenant moi je suis pas devin
mais je pense que les gens ne veulent
pas de cette forme de de passation de
pouvoir en force sur les retraites je
pense qu'il faut qu'on trouve vraiment
essayé de ça peut être que le
gouvernement qui peut trouver ça une
concertation entre les représentants du
peuple
et puis le peuple et puis le pouvoir
actifs parce qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui je
pense que cette recette réforme est très
mal vécue elle n'est pas vécue comme une
injustice
elle est vécue comme une injustice nous
mêmes la police on n'est pas d'accord
avec la retraite peut-être quand nous
les pauses on est sûre on n'a aucune
garantie aucune garantie non ce qu'on
veut c'est l'alignement police
gendarmerie
est ce qu'on leur a pour l'interrogation
on est des policiers régalien ont fait
ne travaille que nous devons faire vous
le voyez malheureusement mais nous
sommes de tout coeur avec des gens qui
ont des vrais doléances et les pompiers
qui sont issus de la société civile qui
sont des gens comme vous et moi qui met
qui met qui mettent leurs uniformes et
qui mettent leur vie en péril pour nous
sauver sont des gens qui méritent le
plus profond respect et d'avoir aussi le
respect de la nation
et puis avec des gouvernants évidemment
christophe crépin je vous propose de
repartir
du côté de la place de la nation pour
retrouver guillemin rossi guimard aussi
on aperçoit toujours ces images de
barricades anti émeute a placé par la
préfecture de police de paris pour
éviter que les pompiers n'accède au
boulevard périphérique
je vous dit être toujours pas peut-être
que vous vous rapprochez de de cette
zone géographique mais
globalement et
quelle est l'ambiance tout à l'heure à
votre micro on avait un pompier
qui évoqué le chiffre d'un blessé ce que
vous avez des informations sur son état
de santé
et par rapport à l'ambiance de votre
côté alors pas d'autres informations
concernant l'état de se confier en
revanche un autre pompier venu me dire
que certains de leurs de ses collègues
avaient reçu des tirs de gaz lacrymogène
tout à côté de la place de la nation aux
abords d'une bouche de métro et il est
vrai que comme vous l'avez préciser
certains accès de cette place de la
nation sont totalement barricades et il
est impossible de les franchir le
dispositif policier est quant à lui très
très très important on peut voir en
faisant le tour de cette place de la
nation plusieurs dizaines voire quelques
centaines en fait de membres de forces
de l'ordre
donc vous voyez derrière moi la place de
la nation où il ya toujours énormément
de pompiers pour le moment il n'est pas
question de dispersion en tout cas cela
n'a pas été
cela n'a pas été la consigne n'a pas été
donné pour une dispersion et de l'autre
côté le cours de vincennes où il ya
toujours aussi beaucoup d'activités ou
nous irons dans un instant il ya la
plupart des pompiers en réalité se
dirigent vers ce cours de vincennes où
l'on voit au loin des plusieurs des
nuages de gaz sans que l'on sache si ce
souci ce sont des gaz lacrymogènes ou
s'il s'agit de simples de simple
fumigène toujours une ambiance qui
oscillant en réalité entre l' ambiance
plutôt festive avec de la musique avec
des pompiers qui rit les pompiers qui
parlent entre eux et de l'autre côté des
pétarades et des forces de l'ordre qui
donc dont on sent qu'elles sont prêtes à
intervenir à tout moment aux moindres au
moindre débordement en tout cas elles
sont elles sont au nombre sont venus en
nombre pour cela et puis on voit il
avait vu les pompiers avec leurs casques
et c'est de toute façon pas tenues
anodine puisque cela d'ailleurs été été
critiqué en tout cas on attend de savoir
comment va se dérouler la suite de cette
manifestation est ce que tout ceci va se
terminer est ce que les pompiers vont
être convaincus ou pas par les annonces
qui seront faites à l'issue des de cette
réunion avec l'intersyndicale et le
ministre de l'intérieur ou alors est-ce
que l'on reviendra à un dénouement comme
on avait connu en fin d'année dernière
vous entendez encore les pétarades
toujours sur cette place de la nation
est ce qu'on reviendra donc encore une
fois ce type d'aidé mouvement ne sais
pas encore tout ceci va certainement se
décider dans les prochaines dizaine de
minutes peut-être les prochaines heures
merci guimard aussi en direct donc de la
place de la nation on aperçoit certaines
images assez forte ici un homme en
fauteuil roulant on a aperçu également
des pompiers posée
telle une photo de famille comme si
c'était avant un match de football un
aperçu également des jets de canon à eau
de la part des forces de l'ordre postées
derrière ces barricades antiémeutes ont
aperçu aussi des pompiers eh bien
tantôt procédé la photo de famille
tantôt à faire la queue leu leu c'est
assez surprenant comme comme image
il ya de la confusion
christophe crépin vous êtes toujours
présent avec nous sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
du syndicat de police france police
policiers en colère qui m'a rossi a
évoqué des des grenades on a vu
d'ailleurs sur ces images on voit des
fusils fumigènes mais concernant les
grenades quelles sont ces types de
grenades qui sont employés des grenades
lacrymogènes des grenades de
désencerclement des grenades cli f4 on a
entendu le ministre
castaner parler du retrait de ces
fameuses grenades qui ont blessé des
études de communication en fait la glnf
4010 le plus uni plus commercialisés et
donc on a une grenade qui est sans tnt
est à rien sans explosif mais les effets
pyrotechniques est exactement le même
moi j'engage les manifestants ne pas
essayer de reprendre des grenades qui
ont été lancée parce que là vraiment il
est qu'ils exposent leur vie et nous
mêmes nous avons eu des blessés dans nos
rangs avec des jets de grenades mais
l'agly f4 n'existe plus nous avons des
grenades de désencerclement qui font du
bruit et qui au fond un effet de souffle
je ne sais pas quelle qu'elles sont des
grenades qui sont utilisés je pense que
si on est certainement dû lacrymogène
pour essayer de canaliser pour éviter
qu'il y ait trop de débordements mais
mais voilà quoi en fait
et on aperçoit ici justement un fumigène
qui a été projeté par dessus la barrière
de sécurité séparant ont donc anti
émeutes pour éviter que certains
manifestants ne passe de l'autre côté
pour rejoindre le boulevard périphérique
il a eu un tout à l'heure en début
d'après-midi un côté du périphérique a
été emprunté brièvement par parler les
pompiers inadmissible selon la
préfecture de police de paris christophe
crépin tout à l'heure également en début
de cortège qui a eu
des périodes de tension entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
avec a priori deux cents à trois cents
pompiers qui aurait voulu prendre un
chemin annexes non déclarés
comment est-ce que ça son terrain en
tant que policier vous vous de gérer mon
cher exactement la même situation et
c'est que l'équipe derrière qui a été
pré établis soit il respecté parce qu'on
veut pas être partout et donc en fait
les personnes qui ont voulu s'extraire
ils ont été vite rui dans le chemin de
la manifestation déclarée
je ne sais pas quelles étaient leurs
intentions mais il faut qu'ils restent
dans le parcours qui est déclarée
regardez ces images en direct avec des
manifestants qui s'agglutinent en
direction de
de ces barrières anti-émeute avec
passion c'est quand même que accéder aux
périphériques pour eux c'est peut-être
valeur symbolique mais ils mettent ils
exposent leur vie on les expose leur vie
et des véhicules qui circulent il y a il
ya une possibilité de pouvoir des
accidents très graves
je pense que ça sert à rien qu'ils
actions périphériques qui peuvent très
bien être entendu l'a28 sont justement
concernant le dénouement entendu guimard
aussi notre envoyé spécial sur place
être dans l'interrogation selon vous
coûte de la dispersion du mulet nouveau
et j'espère qu'ils vont comprendre que
toute façon la violence n'apporte rien
même si nous ne pas risquer syndical on
est tout à fait avec eux dans les
doléances qu'ils expriment ils leur
poids vrai statut il leur faut qu'ils
soient il reconnu dans la dangerosité du
métier qu'ils exercent même s'ils sont
et surtout si ce sont des volontaires
parce que c'est beau aujourd'hui d'avoir
des gens qui sont volontaires pour leur
pays pour porter assistance alors aux
citoyens de notre beau pays en fait mais
je ne sais pas quelle sera la décision
du ministre de l'intérieur j'espère
qu'il aura entendu écouté qui prônera un
vrai statut pour ces gens qui le
méritent
puisqu'on le rappellent les syndicats
reçus dans l'après midi au ministère de
l'intérieur pour discuter de tous ces
sujets en rappellant que la prime de feu
n'a pas été revalorisé depuis 1990 est
l'une des demandes une des
revendications inde et des pompiers
aujourd'hui à noter que le préfet de
police de paris
didier lallement
sur le twitter de la préfecture de
police de police demande aux
organisateurs d'après à la dispersion de
la manifestation
et cette manifestation on y retourne au
coeur si je puis dire avec mona amoud et
leur monnaie ou est-ce que vous vous
situez on aperçoit de plus en plus
d'image proche du boulevard périphérique
est ce que vous aviez eu accès à ce
boulevard périphérique
en tous les cas du côté des barrières
anti-émeute que certains manifestants
temple de force en tous les cas on le
voit sur ces images en direct un simple
victime là bas avec des canons à eau ici
à l'image en direct
c'est violent ce sont des scènes confuse
a priori vous êtes un petit peu plus
loin mais ce que vous arrivez à
apercevoir ce qui se passait
[Musique]
oui exactement ans grégory je me suis
éloigné de cette de la place de la
nation et je suis les barricades sont à
quelques quelques centaines de mètres de
moi justement on a on a eu un petit
quelques frictions mais pour l'instant
de la part des sapeurs-pompiers rien de
très très dangereux en tout cas pas une
grande confrontation et je vous le
disais il vient ce cortège il est
composé de plusieurs syndicats qui nous
viennent de tout est la france je suis
justement avec grégory chaillot de
l'unsa du 78 bonjour à vous merci d'être
avec nous à 14 heures il y avait sept
ans réunion avec l'intersyndicale des
sapeurs pompiers et le gouvernement
qu'est ce que vous attendez
en fait on a ça se portaient surtout sur
la prime de feu cette réunion donc en
fait on est en position dangereuse en
éclat sans profession dangereuse et pour
cela comme la police il fallait être à
28%
donc c'est de salaire de base c'est un
calcul ce qu'on appelle anciennement la
prime de feu toujours la prime de feu
est là tuez-le mans nous elle était à
19% de vous dire
une trentaine d'années a jamais évolué
et voyons la retraite arrivée avec les
poings et le comment dire le système
macron et un moment de salaire comme on
a des salaires bas dans la fonction
publique un il faut bien que quand même
que le privé le sache
il ya un moment bas sur les primes
forcément pour essayer de remonter et
perdre le moins possible
voilà donc risquer des faits aujourd'hui
donc on a demandé une prime à 25%
apparemment donc je vais pas m'avancer
on attend de savoir
l'intersyndicale nationale de ce qu'elle
va nous dire et apparemment on a encore
toujours sur la proposition à 25% ce qui
n'allait pas déjà cette semaine me
demande vraiment à 28% une bonne fois
pour toutes qui nous donne ce qui nous
revient de droit
ce qui n'a jamais été fait et ce que
c'est ce qu'on attend depuis des années
quoi il ya eu plusieurs réunions
justement à ce sujet la dengue 17
janvier et les sapeurs pompiers n'ont
vraisemblablement pas été convaincu par
ce qui a été à discuter argumenter
non parce qu'en fait on a un système de
retraite est assez compliqué parce qu'on
fait des bonifications il nous faut 27
ans de service opérationnel
justement où c'est une année pour cinq
avant c'était 25 s'est monté à 27 de
cotisation on sait rien on nous donne
les grandes lignes on nous dit oui vous
allez voir partir à 57 bien 57 ans
avaient qu avec la moitié note notre
retraite il ya trop d'inconnues
il ya l'artiste espèces d'articles 36
qui a été mis ou ne sais pas trop en
gros ce qu'ils veulent quand ils veulent
nous ça nous voit pas on ne vous
vraiment des choses très précises et
comme pour toutes les professions
rien n'est précis c'est pour ça que les
gens qui sont à la rue il faut bien
comprendre que tout ce qui explique aux
gens ils en donnent qu'une partie et
nous on veut tout le monde veut tout
connaître sur la retraite il ya aussi
cette réforme des retraites aussi qui
vous préoccupe ouais bien sûr c'est ce
que je suis en train de vous expliquer
c'est ce que je vais expliquer c'est
c'est assez flou j'ai même fait des
piges en 2019 aussi et c'était pas que
leur alors il y avait à la retraite et
aussi les agressions mais quand même pas
mal de choses qui étaient dans le paquet
gens on va dire ça comme ça mais oui à
la retraite
la retraite c'est trop flou on a des
grandes lignes mais sans avoir vraiment
les barrières exactement serviront peut
se passer personne ne comprend rien à
l'heure qu'il est ou très peu de choses
c'est une grande inconnue en fait c'est
tout est flou on ne sait pas donc comme
on sait pas tant qui a rien d'écrit noir
sur blanc est signé du ministre eh bien
on sera dans la rue voilà il ya
plusieurs pompiers qui j'ai pu parler
qui me parlait d'un manque de
reconnaissance dans la profession bah
oui ce que vous savez c'est un métier
assez bas
on voit les coulisses de la vie donc on
est en première ligne pour tous dans
tous les domaines
on en prend plein la figure que ce soit
pareil dans tous les domaines
moment c'est bon on est dans l'ombre
depuis des années alors c'est bon on a
là on a la population qui est quand même
derrière nous parce qu'on leur vient en
aide régulièrement enfin tout le temps
j'ai envie de vous dire mais il ya un
moment faut que soit reconnu alors c'est
pour ça que
est ce qu a expliqué rapidement ce qui
s'est passé tout à l'heure ici juste le
président parisien s'est pas passé grand
chose
les qui se colle est bonne et les
barricades sans rien faire de mal parce
qu'elles sont pas bougé et forcé les
cadres ou et
classique wade père c'est quoi
du spectacle mais rien de méchant très
bien merci à vous pour ce témoignage
vous l'avez entendu à grégory pour
l'instant des manifestants ont les
sapeurs pompiers qui restent mobilisés
et qui attendent ce qui va en ressortir
de cette réunion qui était prévue avec
le gouvernement aux alentours de 14
heures
merci mon amoud et l'or en direct donc
de cette manifestation des pompiers pour
dénoncer le manque d'effectifs et de
reconnaissance de leur profession et
réclamé des garanties pour leur retraite
est également demandé une
hausses de leurs primes de 5 % du
salaire de base contre 19% actuellement
on voit un des gaz lacrymogènes ici du
côté des bars pompe
certains pompiers certains manifestants
tentent d'enfoncer christophe crépin
vous êtes toujours présent sur sur ce
plateau vous êtes rappelle le porte
parole du syndicat france police
policiers en colère vous disiez tout à
l'heure ils ne passeront pas assez sûr
quand on voit certaines des images on a
l'impression que les portes elle va si
un petit peu c'est pas des potes en fait
ce sont des grilles qui sont mis devant
des véhicules en fait qu'ils sont là
j'ai pour éviter que il ya un
franchissement c'est des grilles qui
sont hyper solide c'est le système qui
fait que les unes avec les autres font
un mur qui serait infranchissable et
toute façon je pense qu'ils passent
quand c'est sûr parce que le premier
luzira lent alors il peut peut-être pas
passées par sept par ce chemin mais
selon la préfecture de police
de paris certains manifestants pénètrent
dans des immeubles privés cours de
vincennes afin de contourner le
dispositif pour atteindre le
périphérique est ce que ça c'est
possible et vous 1 100 policiers qu'est
ce que vous faites pour empêcher les
pompiers récolter les petits groupes
d'intervention de la compagnie jet d'eau
pc de paris qui ont dû les lui les voir
et qui vont un peu qu'ils vont les
interpeller penche l'état
surtout qu'en plus la pension et et
ovale siège des compagnies républicaines
de sécurité pour je pense pas devant
passer par là il essaye c'est le jeu en
fait un power moi je pense pas qu'ils
passeront oui comme vous recommande donc
vos caméras mal le fond voire en fait
c'est une solidarité totale avec ses
clefs bat pour éviter justement qu'ils
puissent passer en fait un on a perçu
tout à l'heure sur d'autres images aux
alentours de 16h 5d gilet jaune présent
au sein de cette manifestation n'a perçu
jérôme rodriguez et phau 6 lellouche de
figure emblématique du mouvement des
gilets jaunes le fait
qui est déjà les jaunes présence du
cortex a9 quoi là toute façon les
pompiers sont ici de la suite civile les
pentes assistance à la france en fait
donc les jeunes essayent de récupérer
tout ce qui est doléances pour pouvoir
se faire entendre également quand on
fait un léger les jaunes pour nous nous
pensions qu'ils avaient de doléances qui
était dès lors légitime après c'est
parti dans n'importe quel sens si on a
eu des bad blocks qui sont venus se
greffer mais je suis pas surpris qu'ils
aient des gilets jaunes qui viennent
pour essayer de récupérer pour s creed
est en hausse comme toute façon d'une
grève très grande fracture sociale dans
le pays
je pense que la seule réponse qui fut
est à participer par le gouvernement
certaines époques en avoir un
groupuscule de pompiers assez énervé
tenter toujours d'enfance et ses parcs
ont cessé barricades
l'attention des gens qui ont un niveau
sportif très conséquent des gens qui
accepte ou sur le physique
ils sont très très très physique assez
forte de cette mobilisation des pompiers
une mobilisation qui a perturbé une
conférence de presse tenue par la maire
de paris anne hidalgo dans le 11e
arrondissement selon john a list
cigare au chômage ces différentes
informations concernant cette
mobilisation des sapeurs pompiers à la
veille on le rappelle d'une mobilisation
nationale interprofessionnelle contre la
réforme des retraites à l'appel d'une
intersyndicale
allez les revendications des pompiers
quelles sont elles regardez
[Musique]
moi quand les pompiers de france sont là
présents aujourd'hui la première
application sera tout d'abord comme
beaucoup de français qui le peuvent
justement n'être pas la présence par
rapport aux primes au public
par rapport aux retraites c'est à dire
que sapeur-pompier aujourd'hui ne pas
partir à 59 en retraite c'est pas
possible on a un métier qui est pénible
qui est difficile quand la nuit ont subi
les agressions bien là le métier se
complique
la france va mal
aujourd'hui et on le voit dans plein de
profession mais dans l'année voilà donc
un pompier un manifestant au micro de
mona hameau dès lors tout à l'heure au
cours donc de cette manifestation
aurélien qui en vient de nous rejoindre
sur ce plateau bonjour vous êtes confié
sa joie au vu de votre uniforme
vous êtes secrétaire départemental du
syndicat sud
au pas de calais et
je suppose que vous étiez présent tout à
l'heure à la manifestation oui la soie
présent depuis depuis le début de la
manifestation jusqu'à la place nation
quel est l'état d'esprit des pompiers de
vaud de vos confrères
quand on voit certaines images assez
forte en voit certains de vos confrères
tenter d'enfoncer les barreaux pour
passer de l'autre côté sur le
périphérique pourquoi vouloir aller sur
le périphérique et vous leur passé ces
barrières anti-émeutes
c'est difficile à dire je peins dans
leur tête mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est quand même pas mal de pompiers qui
sont un peu à bout après quand même
plusieurs mois de grève et à ce que ça
je cesse de vouloir veiller rien jusque
là rien justifiée parce que encore une
fois on a eu une manifestation 14 le 15
octobre dernier s'est passé exactement
de la même manière ou place nation on a
été menacé et on pouvait pas rejoindre
nos bus où on s'est fait gazer cherche
pas d'excusé ou quoi que ce soit il y en
a qui sont plus énergiques d'autres
certainement toujours est il que depuis
quand même le mot de joie l'année
dernière ont sonné en grève et que les
réponses à cette grève de la part du
gouvernement
on parle de non violence physique sauf
qu'il ya de la violence psychologique
qui fait par le gouvernement depuis que
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
sur les pompiers justement il ya une
réunion cet après-midi au ministère de
l'intérieur avec les syndicats pour
discuter de divers sujets discutés
évidemment de vos revendications
qu'est ce que vous attendez qu'est ce
qui peut se passer après c'est alors et
vous dépendre résultats de cette réunion
je n'ai pas été destinataire de ce qui
s'est dit à cette réunion chez que nous
au niveau de notre syndicat me soumises
devait nous recevoir sauf qu'apparemment
il a trouvé autre chose à faire on qui
ne sera pas utile d'en recevoir jeu tout
dépend ce qui a été dit si on a des
avancées sur nos revendications le
mouvement s'arrêtera et tout le monde
repartira demain enfin je veux dire nous
on n'est pas content d'être là je veux
dire moi je préfère être dans ma caserne
dans ma maison avec ma famille plutôt
que de venir manifester ainsi tout
allait bien la préfecture de police de
paris a dit que certains manifestants
pénètrent dans des immeubles privés
cours de vincennes afin de contourner le
dispositif pour atteindre le permis mais
qu'est-ce que vous confirmer cette
information
moi non c'est souvent fait qu'on rentre
dans des immeubles privés parce que pour
parce qu'on est bon enfant parce qu'on
va dire bonjour aux gens parce que on
veut prendre des photos vues de deux ans
au donc on va sur les étages un ou deux
ou trois quatre cinq six
maintenant c'est leur vision des choses
si les considère que les banques aidées
qui sort d'un cortège c'est pour faire
du mal bossé de contourner un system
seller fox est lancée l'horizon des
choses c'est pas la même quel rapport à
ce que vous entretenez avec la police
qui a justement le porte-parole un robot
nécessaire pour la démolition voilà
c'est ça qu'elle est compliquée pour
nous et c'est pour ça beaucoup de
sapeurs-pompiers du 15 octobre qui ont
été blessés ils n'ont pas compris
après l'énervement fait beaucoup de
choses c'est à dire que sous
l'énervement on peut avoir des gestes ou
des paroles provocantes qui qui on
venait un peu la chose mais je dire moi
dans le pas de calais je je je travaille
régulièrement avec les crs ou gendarmes
mobiles
les relations sont très bonnes que c'est
ça quand on est menacé
quand on est encerclée on se dit [ __ ]
parmi les mécontents d'hier pourquoi
pourquoi on vient on veut manifester
faire juste un trajet et du point a au
point b
voilà on n'est pas au fait de toutes les
dispositifs qui sont mis en place qui
sont peut-être dans la norme pour eux
mais non aurélien qui rend je vous
interromps
on repart d'un côté de la place de la
nation en direct pour retrouver mona
amoud et l'or
mon âme ou dès lors de plus en plus de
pompiers affluent vers les parfums
destination donc de la porte de
vincennes avec eux et scène confuse
également qu'en est il exactement
alors attendez un instant grégory juste
que je me positionne ça a été ça a été
assez violent on a été touchés par des
canaux alors qu'on était en train de
deux films et il faut savoir qu'au la
tension est montée d'un cran puisque
plusieurs sapeurs pompiers ont essayé de
pousser ces barricades
on va essayer de s'approcher un petit
mot pour vous montrer un peu
skins passiez tirs de gaz lacrymogènes à
bord de la police pour repousser ces
individus
et là vous pourrez vous et on peut
peut-être le voir grâce aux images
de cynthia lauvergeon
tu vas essayer un petit peu de vous
montrer ce qui se passe actuellement
donc tout le week-end
elle était
j'étais sur le point en fait
de presque être au niveau du camion il
ya une dune michael qui était sur le
point d'être était trop bousculés
et là directement et bien les
les forces de l'ordre ont répliqué à
coups de gaz lacrymogènes et de
et de tirs de canon on est on est tout
trempé on est toutes liées en tout cas
juste sur le bas du corps du courrier un
petit peu mais bruit pas de provision
ici que la tension elle elle monte d'un
cran
faisant fusil excusez moi mais bon vous
dire ici que les sapeurs-pompiers sont
extrêmement en colère en kite ont essayé
de nous briser ces barricades on revient
vers vous car il est impossible de
respirer là
merci monnaie à un mode alors oui
allez-y je suis assez heureux lien en
fait il n'est pas peut-être l'habitude
la communication moi je suis un
professionnel
en fait s'ils veulent aller sur cette
barricade c'est parce qu'elle est
symbolique c'est marie kaddes quant au
gouvernement mais une barricade pour eux
les pompiers qui sont issus de la
société civile
c'est une barricade symbolique tôt que
moi je les engage à surtout ne pas
mettre leur vie en péril
ce genre de symbole j'aurais bien voulu
que mon ministre de tutelle qui le même
que le leur prennent cinq minutes pour
recevoir ces gens issus de la société
civile pour que ministre de l'inde
l'arrière christophe castaner et bien
sûr bien sûr j'aimerais bien que mon
ministre prennent cinq minutes pour
recevoir ces gens est juste faire en
sorte qu'ils soient écoutés entendus et
qu'il essaye de faire en sorte que ces
gens qui seraient intégrés leurs
casernes et qu'on puisse continuer comme
c'était le avant travailler tous les
tous main dans la main oui je peux
passer quelque chose en fait le ministre
a reçu une délégation sur nous notre
syndicat n'a pas été reçue on est en
face et après away ont passé après mais
il a reçu de l'intersyndicale comme
bordeaux mais c'est déjà une bonne chose
mais toujours est il qu'on ne sait je ne
sais pas ce qu'il en est ressorti
en tout état de cause nous la parité
syndicats on le redit les doléances des
pompiers avec qui nous travaillons tous
les jours au quotidien parce que le
travail la police et des pompiers c'est
difficile elle pour nous nous sommes
nous semble quand même légitime
tout à fait et vous avez vous avez
complètement raison avec la barricade
oui c'est ça c'est un symbole ça ça
bloque en plus c'est il ya de la
provocation de part et d'autre on
s'amuse un peu parfois il ya des gestes
simples pour ça je souris parce que
parfois je vois des gestes faits par des
pompiers je veux dire le pompier tout
seul qui pousse une barricade
c'est pas de la provocation c'est de
l'amusement c'est parce que voilà c'est
pas comme si quand j'étais des pavés
c'est pas c'est pas la même violence
qu'on peut rencontrer sur certaines
autres manifestations
il n'y a pas eu je pense pour l'instant
de crs ou gendarmes blessés c'est joli
il est bientôt à 17 heures le cortège a
débuté en début d'après midi
on est arrivé au point final de ce
défilé qui avait lieu entre la place de
la république et la place de la nation
donc un pari à quoi est-ce que vous vous
attendez ce soir jusqu'à quelle heure
entre guillemets ce siège
mais je peux utiliser ce mot peut durer
sur une roue alors le cg va pas durer du
thème éternel jeu dirons nous on doit
tous repartir dans nos départements
c'est pas le but de rester là-bas de
faire un siège toute la nuit
alors j'ai été un peu pessimiste mais je
m'entends pas grand chose de la part du
gouvernement que des annonces qui vont
être faites et c'est ça en fait qui
m'attriste c'est que c'est la deuxième
manifestation nationale qu'on fait en
l'espace de quelques mois ça fait quand
même plus de sept mois huit mois qu'on
est en grève
justement on parle de cette grève contre
la réforme des retraites demain il ya
une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation nationale à l'appel d'une
intersyndicale de l'intersyndicale vous
en tant que pompier au lendemain de
cette manifestation je vous demande est
confiée est ce que vous y serez ou est
ce que parce qu en intervention alors
moi demain des jeux serait de garde
parce que j'étais bien dire je serai
bien demain par contre oui on participe
aux manifestations contre la réforme de
la retraite non
dans l'air une autre sous forme de
sapeurs pompiers parce qu'on est aussi
impactée et intervenant sur toute la
société française on se rend compte
également de certains titres en compte
beaucoup de français et de l'impact pour
fait de cette réforme qui est je dis pas
qu'elle est mauvaise mais elle est
complètement flou on sait pas où on va
nous on sait pas quelle sauce on va être
mangé aurélien acquérant vous êtes donc
mon pied dans le pas-de-calais
il ya des pompiers qui viennent de toute
la france certains de dijon d'autres de
bordeaux a priori sont de gros
contingents improductif
ils sont montés deux côtés de de paris
les pompiers de paris entre unitaire ne
manifestent pas mais est-ce que
vous contact avec eux et qu'est ce qui
manque
les mêmes fantasmes des concurrents ne
pense pas les pompiers de paris sont
soumis à un régime et le régime
militaire est repris de paris sur pas là
pour penser ils ont une hiérarchie qui
est très stricte ne sont pas ici la cité
sélection des professionnels donc c'est
toi qui vont manifester s'ils
manifestent
là ça serait quand même de levage a pour
eux ça par contre c'est tout à fait vrai
cd militaire donc un militaire peut pas
manifester partout et c'est justement
d'où la question entendre militaire et
ne manifestent pas mais qu'est ce qu'il
pense de tout ce qui s'offre avec eux je
pense qu'il y en a qui sont militaires
qui y voit que la vision militaire qui
comprennent pas surtout quand on va
surfer un certain âge est effectué par
mes collègues pour eux c'est peut-être
la fin un peu la tenue mais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de pompiers de paris
sont également conviés dans nos rangs
dans l'union civile grâce au volontariat
et une fois qu'ils ont fini leur
quelques années à paris et reviennent
chez nous donc les manifestations qu'on
fait maintenant
le comté de paris qui va arriver dans le
civil après va en bénéficier de toutes
les avancées qui pourrait avoir d'autres
pensent que moralement ils sont avec
nous même s'ils peuvent pas l'affiché on
repart du côté de la manifestation place
de la nation pour retrouver à guy marrot
silguy main tout à l'heure on était avec
mona hamoud
alors qu'ils étaient à proximité des
parts on du côté de la porte de
vincennes
ou vous est ce que vous vous situez
comment est-ce que ça se passe dans
votre quotidien
[Musique]
il a écouté à peu près au même endroit
parce que vous pouvez peut-être voir la
barricade derrière moi donc qui permet à
graver plus justement qui empêchent
l'accès au périphérique intérieur sur ce
court sur ce cours de vincennes belle
ambiance vous l'avez vu il ya eu de
nombreux tirs de grenades lacrymogènes
qui ont fusé il ya quelques instants
obligeant les pompiers et nous-mêmes du
coup à refluer le gabarit clairement des
de ces grenades qui sont tirées l'emploi
régulier également du canon à eau donc
puisque il faut protéger cette barricade
pour éviter qu'elles qu'elles ne cèdent
vous l'avez dit également que ça avait
été dit par par la préfecture de police
et certains des pompiers ici dont nous
l'ont également dit certains ont tenté
de contourner cette barricade mais se
sont fait attendre de l'autre de l'autre
côté par des tiers de gaz de gaz
lacrymogène et n'ont pas pu rejoindre le
périphérique
donc voilà pour l'instant là l'ambiance
ici est entre
entre entre deux extrêmes d'un coup un
calme parfait et puis deux minutes après
les tirs de grenades lacrymogènes et des
nombreux pompiers qui reflue puis qui
retourne ensuite à la barricade pour se
faire entendre et justement je suis avec
eux loïc et qui est représentant
syndical donc à la cgt loïc merci de
répondre à nos questions encore vous
êtes ici depuis un petit moment et ça
fait donc vous le disiez tout à l'heure
plusieurs mois en fait que vous que vous
manifestez pour vos droits est ce que
vous pensez que vous allez avoir gain de
cause est ce que vous pensez vous allez
pouvoir obtenir ce que vous demandez ce
fameux cette fameuse prime de
l'augmentation de cette prime de feu
donc leurs biens sur toute manière on
lâchera pas tant qu'on n'aura pas eu
gain de cause par rapport aux
revendications donc l'emploi statutaire
supplémentaire de sapeurs pompiers
professionnels avec une réputation la
plume de feu à 28% pourquoi 26% pour
qu'elles soient justement égal à la
police
on estime que notre métier on s'y
risquer que les policiers
malheureusement on le voit tous les ans
avec des collègues décédés
nous estimons aussi que notre métier est
super à a beaucoup plus de risques liés
aux cancers notamment aux fumées au
rythme de travail de 24 heures qui usent
de santé on veut aussi
le retrait du projet doit contre la
retraite bien entendu jouer s'imaginer
racontiez à 60 62 ans qui doit
intervenir sur un incendie et secours à
une personne veut forcément ça risque
d'être compliqué donc toutes et tous et
aux revendications
on lâchera pas tant qu'on n'aura pas
abouti la problématique aujourd'hui
c'est d'avoir de gouvernance donc on a
le ministre de l'intérieur donc qui
renvoie la balle à nos financeurs qui
sont les départements et les mairies qui
eux payent justement les 10 donc chacun
se revend ses responsabilités et ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a du mal à
aboutir en location et vous le disiez
donc là
la journée d'aujourd'hui la mobilisation
d'aujourd'hui elle connaît un certain
succès on a vu des cas plusieurs
milliers de personnes
sauf à cette manifestation tout le monde
du courtage jusqu'ici encore sur la
place de la nation
vous me disiez que vous représentez
avait beaucoup de syndicats qui étaient
représentés
100 des cas présent dans cette
intersyndicale donc du coup on est en
grève depuis le 26 juin 2019 donc on
représente 85% des syndicats des
pompiers de france voilà syndicat
majoritaire unitaire sur leur
embarcation
voilà tout à fait tout à fait
représentatif est ce que vous pensez
on voit que vous avez des défenses de
lot ne dit pas à tirer des gaz
lacrymogènes ce que commence presque
terminés est-ce que ça va se disperser
dans le calme ou en fonction des
annonces qui peut-être seront faites
avant la dispersion est ce que vous
pensez que la mobilisation peut se
maintenir ici que les barricades vont
être forcés à votre arrivée vous avez à
votre avis quel est quel est le but de
devaux de vos collègues ici présents à
le but effectivement c'est d'avoir
comment dire une réponse positive à nos
revendications si vous voulez si vous
n'avez pas qu'est-ce qui si je la
voulais aussi vous avez un refus par
exemple ici cette manière on est en
grève aujourd'hui jusqu'au mois de mars
là aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui va se
passer ça va on va maintenir voilà juste
jusqu'au second puisque en plus après on
a des gars de toute la france qui a
abandonné vont quand même rentrés chez
eux les gars du nord du sud de l'ouest
donc
forcément un moment donné on repartira
mais ça sera pour que pour mieux revenir
pour aboutir nos revendications
merci beaucoup merci saison on vous
l'avez entendu les revendications qui
sont toujours toujours les mêmes et de
cuir en réalité plusieurs mois et même
plusieurs années puisqu'en fait cette
question du statut c'est que la pile de
feu et du rapport en fait de l'égalité
avec d'autres fonctionnaires et
notamment avec des forces de l'ordre
avec la police donc qui est également
reçoivent une prime à 28%
cette question elle n'est pas de
nouvelles de très nombreuses années
cette grève des pompiers elle dure
depuis plusieurs mois et vous en voyez
ici donc le dernier le dernière épisode
dont on attend encore l'issue merci
beaucoup
guimard aussi en direct donc de la place
de la nation ça commence véritablement à
pousser envoie son côté droit une barre
contre en train d'être d'écran levé on
dirait quand ce sont des images en
direct qu'on est en train de vivre sur
arte france on revoit un crs avec son
bouclier de crs mêmes qui sont
directement apportés j'ai envie de dire
des manifestants crespin oui oui mais
moi je suis venu plaquer sur le vécu des
périodes l'accueillir moi je voulais
revenir en fait avec avec des commence à
y avoir quand même des des coups de
matraque
je me permets de vous couper
alors que les images sont quand même
assez assez violente un des scènes de
guérilla urbaine qu'on est en train de
dellys me permets de vous couper pour
repartir en direct du côté de la place
de la nation pour retrouver mona a boudé
leurs monnaies tout à l'heure quand on
vous a quitté il y avait eu des jets de
lacrymogène c'est compliqué pour vous de
parler il ya une porte qui est en train
d'être d'être enfoncé la la situation
vous comment est-ce que vous la vivez
sur place
gori l'ambiance est tellement entendu si
vous l'entendez
rien que les bruins sont extrêmement
extrêmement passionnant en tout cas il
ya sept cette barricade cette baraka qui
va essayer de s'y approcher
on va essayer du mieux qu'on peut en
tout cas vous voyez il ya ce nuage de
fumée est ce cette barricade cette
barricade pied
les adjectifs et s'envole ical
extrêmement importante il vous a brisé
ils ont été plusieurs maisons
ce qu'avaient les forces de l'ordre gaz
lacrymogènes et des tirs de canon de
leur côté les imports confié répliquent
avec des fumigènes vous le voyez injuste
sur ces images des fumigènes et
également des pétards ou simplement ils
essayent de bousculer de pousser cette
barricade
vous le voyez ça c'est compliqué de
tenir ici on nous a dit gentiment 7,7 ce
liquide lac yens un petit peu aux us
excusez moi mais on est en direct ça se
faisait moi ça sont bien vite excusé moi
excusez moi c'est assez c'est assez
agitée donc je voulais c'est une
manifestation qui est qui est tendue
avec des dvd ou des individus qui sont
alcoolisés on va essayer un petit peu de
ses greniers te rapprocher pour
réellement vous montrer ce qu'est ce
qu'il en est regardez sur les images de
cimetière plusieurs sapeurs pompiers se
dirige en direction de cette barricade
il essaye de se motiver les
en tout cas si ce qu'on a pu ressentir
beaucoup beaucoup
et à leurs collègues venez venez on doit
être nommé en boîte plusieurs il faut
montrer qu'on est là plusieurs 20
projectiles ont été lancés on l'a vu
plusieurs va pavés ont été lancés mais
pas seulement
beaucoup de chimie j'ai les deux
de pétards sont élancés en direction
cette barricade on essaie ainsi de
trancher au maximum aux pauvres
c'est réellement
ce qui est en train de se passer en
direct le tout donc
vous l'avez vue sur ces images ne
montrent
st
analyse de la part de beaucoup ici de
sapeurs-pompiers qui sont très très en
colère et qui attend beaucoup de cette
réunion qui avait lieu
le ministre de l'intérieur pour savoir
ce qui va ce qui va en être
on va essayer de s'en rapprocher encore
un petit monde grégory pour que vous
fassiez war est il réellement regarder
je m'en fous j'ai l'impression cette
barricade
ça y est l'été
a été brisée vous pouvez peut-être
rentrer voir sur ces images
plusieurs
lucerne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce mur est arrivé était le briser sa
carrière
à lire
non rien
et c'est trop cher
regardez après goce est mickael chez
elle sans moniteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier en direct
brisée
lisez cette barricade
merci beaucoup mona ahmed alors en
direct donc de la place de la nation
point d'arrivée de ce cortège au revoir
des images assez violente avec un jet de
canons à eau ici de la part des
policiers des forces de l'ordre se sont
postés de l'autre côté donc de ses
barons christophe crépin merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct sur ce
plateau d arte france je rappelle que
vous êtes le porte parole du syndicat
france police policiers en colère merci
à vous on continue à percevoir des
images très très confuse avec donc cette
barricade l'une des barres pour l'une de
ces barrières anti-émeute qui a donc été
forcée qui a cédé sous la pression des
dépenses ils sont mis à plusieurs
exemples ensuite recevoir des
projectiles
de lacrymogène avec également des
déclarants à eau
aurélien qu'ils ont
thaler eux
christophe serait pas inquiété je suis
sûr que la porte-parole dont quatre
passés en colère disait vraiment c
ces barricades elles pourront pas céder
finalement elles ont scellé avec
également la préfecture de police de
paris il ya un post sur twitter qui perd
2,9 tonus des manifestantes bloc
périphériques au niveau du porte de
vincennes et de salons de l'intervention
des forces de l'ordre a permis de
relancer la circulation dans les deux
sens donc il ya eu une incursion sur le
boulevard périphérique alors que là on
est en train de suivre un manifestant a
priori qui est blessé c'est
véritablement en train de s'envenimer
comment ça va se terminer comme toutes
les autres ça veut une manifestation de
sa part ton qui à chaque fois dit
l'expression de cette fois conquis il ya
l'eau perry qui est bloquée un moment
donné à chaque manifestation de pompiers
il ya ça se termine sur la place de la
nation
il disait tout à l'heure à le c'est
symbolique c'est le hard
le fait de l'avoir ouverte voilà les
faits le pompier son centre sont
contents maintenant espérons que le
gouvernement va céder de la même manière
mais je vais pas cautionner
partant que je comprends j'ai beaucoup
de collègues qui sont à bout
ils en ont vraiment marre de je peux pas
cautionner mais je comprends que ça veut
dire que la l'exaspération justifier la
violence ça dépend ce que vous attendez
compte violence
là on parle de violence physique moi
j'ai parlé je leur ai dit ok alors le
choix des images de pompiers pris en
charge par des médecins dreux des strips
ludique
un policier a priori touché à une jambe
un autre à une main et on a entendu tout
à l'heure au micro de guy marosi l'un de
vos confrères évoqué le chiffre de 1
blessé a priori y en aura plus
c'est possible c'est toujours à la fin
où on fait le compte de toute façon donc
ça reste des blessés légers
j'ai tant que ça reste des blessés
légers malheureusement ce n'est pas plus
grave
donc ça en reste là maintenant à chaque
manifestation de sapeurs-pompiers qu'on
ait connu ces dernières années
ça s'est terminé ça s'est passé
exactement de la même manière
c'est juste que ces deux dernières il ya
de l'exaspération dans nos rangs il ya
peut-être un petit peu plus de violence
psychologique mise par le ministère et
gouvernements qui se succèdent
on est face à des gouvernements qui se
succèdent qui sont hypocrites et depuis
des années des années envers les sapeurs
santé enfin nous nous remettre des beaux
discours et des médailles ils n'ont pas
fait grand chose note du post pour vous
parler de les années d année depuis 1990
la prime de feu n'a pas été revalorisée
on repart du côté de la
à porte de vincennes de la place de la
nation pour retrouver dilma rossi
guillemant on a vu certains pompiers
être touché a priori à une main ou à une
jambe
est-ce que vous avez plus d'informations
sur l'état de santé j'en veux dire des
blessés
[Musique]
écoutez c'est un petit peu un petit peu
ça tire beaucoup les barricades ont
failli céder à nouveau il y avait deux
pompiers qui tentaient de faire céder
les barriques à tout ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'il ya là de nombreuses
personnes qui ont été pris en charge par
les palestine medic voyez-vous beaucoup
de pompiers blessés et parfois une jambe
parfois à une main un bras d'un jeune
qui a été transportée on a vu un bon sur
les limaces rossi on reviendra vers vous
d'ici quelques instants on a des
difficultés de liaison on aperçoit en
tous les cas cette image avec de
nombreux de très nombreux un pompier on
le rappelle le 15 octobre dernier lors
de la précédente manifestation les
syndicats évoqué un chiffre compris
entre 7000 et dix mille personnes
aujourd'hui on parle de plusieurs
milliers de pompiers qui défilent
aujourd'hui qui on dénie fils défilé
dans les rues de paris qui sont
maintenant du côté de la place de la
nation n'aura peut-être des chiffres de
plus officiel tout à l'heure en début de
soirée que ça de la part des autorités
ou de la part des organisateurs en tous
les cas là sur ce plateau
jean-pierre colombien c'est bien de nous
rejoindre bonjour vous êtes
le porte parole de l'association union
des policiers nationaux indépendants
vous êtes ancien commandant de police
quand on voit ces images
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'elle vous
évoque de prime abord surtout des nappes
joie de façon dramatique l'opposition
pour des services qui travaillent
quotidiennement ensemble services de
sécurité qui s'engagent écrit ceux qui
prennent des risques physiques et
parfois drôle si le policier mais enfin
quand on arrive aujourd'hui à voir
toutes les strates de la fonction
publique
être obligé de descendre dans la rue et
de yasny fils et vous y avoir vraiment
été vite insupportable
j'en ai se poser les bonnes questions
est de savoir ce qu'on attend pour poser
sur la table des vrais problèmes les
vrais sujets surtout est-ce qu'il ya la
vraie volonté politique ne s'y attaquer
mais ce à quoi on assiste là moi me
désespère gré quand on voit les pompiers
quand on sait le boulot qu'ils font au
quotidien de voir que ils sont en plein
affrontement avec les forces de police
je veux que ce spectacle navrant et
dépendant au revoir en direct en sur ces
images une personne aux salles prise en
charge un attroupement autour d'une
personne a priori donc baisser espérant
évidemment que ce ne soit pas trop grave
on a aperçu évidemment des jets de canon
à eau ont aperçu des lacrymogènes
d'ailleurs quels types de grenades sont
utilisés aujourd'hui que les dispositifs
de sécurité
il ya des tunisiens des lacrymogènes
quand on est d encerclement de glee f4
on en a entendu la part de christophe
castaner dimanche dernier le retrait de
ces grenades qui ont blessé un des
manifestants notamment depuis le 17
novembre 2018 date
la première manifestation des dg les
jaunes d'oeufs
d'armes entre guillemets sont utilisées
aujourd'hui contre les manifestants je
vous ferai de réponse d'évitement mais
tant pis pour la vie à noter que soit le
type de dilution qui sont employés si la
philosophie d'emploi qui compte c'est ce
qu'on veut faire et à quoi on utilise
des forces de maintien de l'ordre
une personne semble-t-il on joue pas on
voit des images transmises en direct les
commente une personne
au stade et des gouttes ophtalmologiques
d'en saisir a priori dont il est le
crime aux jeunes des lacrymo est ce que
ça peut être également des éclats de
voix possible de dire c'est que j'espère
que ce n'est que de la trilogie
enfin quelle que soit la munition on
utilise si elles vous touchent au visage
elle peut occasionner des dégâts
irrémédiables aux professionnels de db
survivre à la 2d zara sarc de
désencerclement pardon si elle est
projetée au niveau supérieur du corps
elle peut occasionner des blessures
vraiment très profond enfin là où il
faut vraiment se poser de bonnes
questions je suis désolé de le dire mais
on a toutes les strates d'un fonction
publique
kilani fait est que ce soit l'éducation
nationale la santé y changera pas la
police
je suis pas là en tant que représentant
de l'institution policière je suis là en
tant que représentant parfois et ainsi
donner la parole au nom de policiers qui
ont eux aussi a ras-le-bol de la façon
dont ils sont commandés malade j'ai
utilisées et aujourd'hui je peux vous
assurer qu'il n'y a pas une majorité de
fonctionnaires de police ravi de servir
je dirais d'ajusteur sociale dans le
cadre des négociations qui sont en cours
comme on parle de deux mouvements de oui
ça fait 40 ans qu'il ya une grève il ya
des mouvements de foule un an et demi
que ça dure un an et demi que nous
sommes passés du moment des vidéos aux
mouvements divers et variés syndicalisme
et et autres à quel moment on va
vraiment posé le problème et ce
gouvernement va-t-il entendre ceux qui
ont des choses à dire et des
propositions à faire
éjaculats dans les syndicats de police
tout simplement comment est-ce que vous
interprétez vous ces images aurélien qui
arrange rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire départemental du syndicat sud
du pas de calais vous est donc venu du
nord de la france pour faire profiter à
7 cette manifestation ces images voir
certains de vos collègues qui sont
administrés des gouttes dans les yeux à
voir certains
un autre qui a priori sont mais c'est
tout le temps on l'a vu des blessures
aux mains ou aux jambes
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque avec des
collègues à bout qui essaie d'enfoncer
des barrières symbole ief c'est en fait
ça m'évoque au niveau des blessures
voire des bouquinistes dans les yeux
c'est du gaz lacrymogène je veux dire je
ne sais vraiment pas de souci là-dessus
c'est habituel on commence on y est là
là là là là c'est je veux dire c'est
violent c'est oui oui pour avoir vécu
d'autres manifestations dans le cadre
des secours j'ai déjà vu des blessés
bien plus grave toujours est-il que
comme lui dise non monsieur à côté en
effet peu importe la munition qui
utilisent et si elle l'utilisé c'est
qu'à un moment donné ils en ont reçu
l'ordre et c'est plus ça en fait qui
m'attriste c'est que encore une fois à
chaque fois qu'on vient c'est la seule
vraie porte au maintien
moi j'en veux pas du tout à mes
collègues gendarmes ou policiers parce
que en fait ils reçoivent juste l'ordre
de fertial et voilà bon après il ya des
mentalités qui s'échauffe de part et
d'autre qui peuvent arriver à des gestes
qui sont plus ou moins violents de part
et d'autre
voilà c'est attristant mais moi ce qui
m'attriste c'est là c'est l'action et la
réponse plutôt la non réponse du
gouvernement
je vous disais tout à leur guise et qui
sont hypocrites depuis des années on a
un gouvernement qui est parfois européen
quand ça l'arrangé a parfois français
quand ça l'arrangé
nous on a des textes européens et qui
nous donne raison à sauf que comme ça va
leur coûter des sous il préférait de
français et faire les lois à la
française par contre si la loi
européenne donnait raison aux ans que le
gouvernement pour payer moins cher il
serait vite on revient donc en fait
c'est ça qu'ils ont ils sont hypocrites
sûr de la manière dont il gère depuis
des années ils veulent faire discuter de
l'année je rappelle que la prime de deux
feux n'a plus été revalorisé depuis 1990
donc avec plusieurs gouvernements avant
cela évidemment leur pour vertement au
lendemain des redevances à l'épaule du
gouvernement chirac etc
c'est l'époque ont demandé 25 % pour
dire ça remonte parce qu'à l'époque la
prime de risque de policiers était de 25
ans et maintenant vous demandez jeu
consistant du salaire de base quand 3
19% accès sans pour être à chaque fois
qu on a des discours on met sur les
forces de sécurité publique dont il a
conquis la police et la gendarmerie et
au final on voit que les policiers on a
tous été pompier sur l'a19
en quoi mon métier est moins dense je ne
dis pas qu'on a les mêmes missions
mais c'est parfois on a je pense au
temps de laisser malheureusement autant
de morts dans nos rangs
dans les rangs de la police on voit
évidemment ce qui se passe dans la rue
en aperçoit également sur les côtés on
le voit pas forcément n'entend pas
forcément on aperçoit également des
vitrines qui sont baissées il ya des
commerçants on peut y avoir des
restaurants qu'est-ce que
vous dites à ces personnes qui au final
n'ont rien demandé à personne et qui
sont des victimes collatérales tout ça
breakfast a demandé à préfecture choisi
un autre trajet voilà c'est pas moi qui
ai choisi le trajet quoi ça j'écoutais
plusieurs configurations
tout à leur taille et des choses qui
sont quand même hallucinant je
l'entendais dire qu'ils avaient
quasiment famille attendre d'être un
point de non retour pour obtenir une
note au ministre de l'intérieur et
d'avoir une écoute d'une certaine
manière dans quelle république vous
invitons où il faut aller juste retenir
la castagne on peut dîner mais pour
avoir une écoute un dialogue et des
propositions enfin je sais ça que je
comprends pas on a dit que justement on
est dans une situation de blocage en
tout cas en pâtit des années et on en
arrive à un moment donné on bat pour se
faire entendre il faut aller dans la rue
sont pliés fort est effectivement passée
à des actes passés à la vitesse
supérieure d'une certaine manière et ce
qui est insupportable d'entendre c'est
que justement il faut attendre d'en
arriver là pour que il ya un semblant
d'écouter tout ce que j'ai pu comprendre
encore c'était pas vraiment des
propositions fermes mais des engagements
faits le voir à la va vite mais ce n'est
pas véritablement officialisé par pas
sanctuariser c'est ça donc à partir de
là c'est encore une fois de plus la
porte ouverte à des mobilisations
antérieures mais ça concerne les pieds
quand je le répète ça concerne aussi la
police qui fait partie de la grande
maison de la fonction publique qui est
donc exactement à la même enseigne que
c'est que ses petits camarades de
l'éducation nationale ou de la santé et
que ce qui se joue aujourd'hui au delà
de ce qu'ils sont ce qui est en jeu pour
les pompiers cette système social qui
est que nous avons en france est-ce
qu'on veut encore dans ce pays une
fonction publique un service public tel
qu'on l'a connu
apparemment non on veut glisser vers une
sorte de système à l'anglo-saxonne opéra
qui voudra qui voudra bien
beaucoup sont ne sont pas de cet avis et
apparemment ce qui est exprimé
actuellement dans les rues mais c'est là
où il ya un problème c'est qu'on n'est
pas du tout ce même logiciel ou
gouvernement on est sur une dynamique
née néolibérale avec un engagement sur
le déclassement des missions de service
public vers des officines privées et là
ça pose un vrai problème du mois ça pose
un problème de société et un dialogue de
société qui n'est pas qui n'est réglé
que par une opposition frontale entre
services services divers services
institutionnels et des services de
police comme si la police était
finalement le l'échelon de négociation
indispensable avant d'arriver aux portes
des ministères ce n'est pas entendable
de mon point de vue et y compris pour la
police qui suit donc dans l'image se
déprécie à une vitesse qu'on n'a jamais
vus parce qu'effectivement elle apparaît
comme l'interlocuteur idoine de tous les
ministères et ses parts en table pour
parler d'eux
image de la police qui est en train de
chuter quant à elle des scènes comme sa
violente de la part des pompiers qui
sont d'habitude apprécié la part de la
population française puisque ce sont les
pompiers qui viennent porter les
premiers secours
est ce que ça peut porter atteinte à
l'image des pompiers vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique française
c'est possible oui c'est possible et
c'est compréhensible veut dire les
personnes qui n'y voit on les
sapeurs-pompiers des gens qui viennent
sauver pas des gens qui agressent la
police donc oui en effet je peux
comprendre que ça peut que choquer et en
faire pâtir un peu notre notoriété
auprès de la population
mais ça reste anodin par rapport à 6 que
tout ce qu'on subit depuis des années je
veux dire on est on est pas là on
collecte par les à côtés des autres
services
il ya également dans le cortège des jeux
procès aux infirmiers et les hôpitaux
nous on travaille tous les jours aussi
également avec les affaires que les
hôpitaux ou les urgences et on voit ce
dépérir le service médical actuel vous
parlez à des personnels hospitaliers
présent au sein du cortège aujourd'hui
on a aperçu également deux figures
emblématiques des gilet jaune crise au
sein du cortège jérôme rodriguez et
laifaoui jean de luz le fait qu'il soit
présent à vos côtés comment ce que vous
l'analysez et comment est ce que vous le
percevez alors moi personnellement je
peux dire que je m'en fous parce que
tout soutien est bon à prendre
je vois pas où est le souci long
manifeste pour nos retraites je pense
que le mouvement des jeunes manifestent
aussi pour ça
j'ai pas dire qui doit être présent ou
pas présent dans le cortège de mon appel
à manifester les pompiers s'il y en a
qui se reconnaissent qu'ils veulent nous
soutenir
non partant au moment où ils le font
dans des mesures légale et cohérente
avec eux mêmes
il n'y a aucun souci quoi je veux dire
tant qu'il ya pas de récupération
politique n'est pas tout soit comme on a
pu l'entendre parfois vous jean pierre
cohen ps je fais un petit peu
embarrassée parce que je suis un petit
peu dans la position qui représente une
institution de bon gré mal gré est-ce
que des jd je n'ai pas de gilet jaune
dans la manifestation des policiers
qu'il a eu il ya quelques mois mais j'ai
presque envie de vous dire qu'ils
auraient pu y être puisque ce qui était
exprimée ce soit par les gilet jaune ou
par toutes les corporations le voit ici
à l'image un jérôme rodriguez justement
en train de saluer des
notre d'autres manifestants et à ses
côtés donc faouzi lellouche les gilet
jaune qui le gilet jaune qui peut
d'ailleurs se confondre avec les bandes
fluorescentes jaune présente le futur
sur le livret a et des pompiers
j'ai envie de vous tout le monde en a
peu dans les hauteurs de peur et c'est
non mais qui soit là et que ce soit sur
la voie publique et participe où
s'agrègent à une manifestation il en a
parfaitement le droit il faut toujours
faire la part des choses
j'ai participé à beaucoup de plateau
télé où on commentait dans les
manifestations que j'ai des jaunes je
crois que là on a utilisé pas mal de
raccourcis faciles entre ce qui est
exprimé la grande majeure partie des
manifestants et quelques blocs qui eux
essayé effectivement de déstabiliser et
de donner une autre teinte à ces
manifestations que je qualifie mois de
populaire un pas de gilet jaune gilet
jaune ça veut rien dire
c'était des gens de la population très
diverse et variée à l'égaler dans ces
manifestations
quand j'y suis allé pour me rendre
compte de qui se trouvaient qu'ils
battaient le pavé
vous aviez tout des personnes âgées des
coûts des enfants parfois c'est pas très
recommandé nima lynchage ou la corde
mais il y avait de tout et aussi des
black blocks bien sûr mais c'était quoi
c'était un centième de la manifestation
et tout le monde s'il focaliser tout le
monde a fait ce qu avec des jabs hoc
aujourd'hui au sein de la manifestation
parmi les personnes qui ont tenté
d'enfoncer les
les barricades ont avisé personne
masquée mais on avait également des
paupières ouais sicilia et pompiers sont
masquées pour se protéger des gaz
également des fumigènes quand on peut
avoir sur toute la manifestation ils
sont pleins masqué pour couvrir leur
visage
c'est noka boule de feu mais ça peut
être ça permet de terminer comme ça je
comprends
après des black blocks je pense que je
n'ai pas connaissance qui ait une seule
vitrine cassée ou détérioré sur le
parcours donc c'est pour ça je vois pas
un black blocks allait enfoncer au quoi
que ce soit sur le parcours parce que
tout simplement c'est pas de ma critique
et je pense qu'il doit et éviter vite
rappelé à l'ordre par c'est déjà arrivé
sur certaines manifestations
départementales
c'est pas leur mode de fonctionnement
journée les groupes black block agissent
de manière beaucoup plus facile lorsque
des manifestations sont d'ampleur
qu'elle réunit des dizaines de milliers
de personnes là on aller face à un
groupe d'officiers
ce que l'espèce des moins pour beaucoup
se connaissent et connaissent et ils
n'ont aucun intérêt
effectivement est ce qu'il sait déborder
par des groupuscules ou identitaires ou
autre je pense que là ce n'est pas le
débat le débat il est que et une colère
et ça va bien falloir les prendre en
compte
elle s'exprime aujourd'hui face à des
façades et c'est assez j'espère que ni
d'un côté ni de l'autre y aura deux
blessés sérieux vraiment parce que si ce
serait une catastrophe mais ne voyons
pas des black blocs partout voyons-nous
colère il ya une colère elle est
institutionnel les les profondes ne pas
l'entendre et dangereux je vous coupe
parce qu'on voit on vient d'apercevoir à
l'image
mona amoud et leur présente au sein du
cortège à ses côtés des pompiers
évidemment mon âme ou dès lors peut-être
juste avant de questionner votre invité
on a aperçu tout à l'heure des blessés
certains manifestants certains pompiers
être pris en charge par des strips medic
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur des éventuelles blessures
aujourd'hui
alors écoutez grégory je n'ai pas les
chiffres exacts en cours en tout cas
j'ai pu constater j'ai pu le voir il ya
quelques blessés en effet qui ont été
pris en charge soit par des pompiers
soit par des street mehdi qui ont été
blessé à la jambe ou encore à la tête
également d'aider les jeunes qui étaient
présents lors de ce rassemblement et
dans ce cortège aussi qu'ils étaient
vraisemblablement des street
medic également ils ont aidé qui ont
secourus ces gens là il ya eu plusieurs
distributions de liquide pour ceux qui
avaient qui avait reçu du gaz
lacrymogène on a été également nous a
gentiment également donné un peu de
celui qui pour pouvoir ouvrir les yeux
et puis voir un peu plus clair en tout
cas pour le moment le hockey c'est un
peu plus calme quoique vous l'entendez
juste derrière moi savary c'est assez
inattendu
je vais donner je vais laisser la parole
à un sapeur-pompier bon jeu en vue merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes venu du
vaucluse pour présenter oui bonjour de
christophe bouchet je suis sapeur
pompier professionnel dans le vaucluse à
avignon et c'est également président du
syndicat autonome du 84 très bien mais
pourquoi c'est important pour vous
manifester depuis juin 2019
j'ai parlé à plusieurs collègues qui
nous est extrêmement important de
manifester manifester surtout
qu'aujourd'hui il ya cette réunion avec
le gouvernement qu'est ce que vous
attendez
mais en fait on en attend enfin que le
gouvernement
comprennent nous entendons nous
comprennent surtout on a des
revendications qui pour nous sont
légitimes
nous avons un stream de feu qui est qui
existe depuis 1996 qui n'a toujours pas
été réévalué depuis donc on attache que
justement la valeureuse revalorisation
par dans la surface et
et il y aura pris au bout si bien
d'autres sujets que notamment aux
réformes sur les retraites où on est
également impactée vous voulez en
retraite un peu de départs à la retraite
anticipée c'est ça c'est oui on peut
dire ça c'est on a la possibilité de
partir cinq ans à vendre mais sous
certaines conditions
c'est à dire qu'il faut avoir travaillé
au minimum 27 ans et avoir surcotiser
c'est à dire qu'on nous fait c'est pas
un cadeau que nous fait c'est une
surcotisation que le pays ait tous les
tous les mois qui quittent allant de 4
personnes de plus sur la cotisation
retraités aujourd'hui
lol et où sa part confiant une jouissent
d'une bonne réputation entouré d'une
bonne image au sein de la population
quels sont les coulisses du métier jeune
et j'ai pu parler avec beaucoup de
conflits qui n'explique c'était un
métier extrêmement un pénible
oui en fait c'est surtout le mérite de
travail qui sont compliquées nous
faisons des gardes de 24 heures donc que
nous arrivait de
des gardes et ne pas dormir ce
physiologiquement c'est compliqué donc
nous on demande aussi au niveau national
que soit enfin pris en compte de cette
pénibilité au travail et surtout de
d'organiser nos temps de travail à un
organiseur l'un des gardes de 12 ans
c'est sûr que là actuellement il faut
comprendre qu'elle sapeurs-pompiers qui
travaillait 24 heures mais pays en
moyenne que 17 ou 18 heures sur ces
fêtes 14 en plus on a vu ici
la tension monte d'un cran il a eu ces
frictions
est-ce que les pompiers sont sont
taboues finalement oui bien sûr c'est
justement parce que le mouvement dure
depuis joué que le gouvernement on
arrive à des situations comme ça qu'ils
voient les placements en beauté on a
envie de comparer deux et qu'on va faire
mais on les comprennent ce que je suis
c'est tout
selon vous cette mobilisation elle va
perdurer on attend de voir l'évolution
je demande de la réunion qui a vu
aujourd'hui si les évolutions sont
favorables pour notre corporation
on pourra éventuellement arrêter le
mouvement tout au moins de diminuer
est ce que vous êtes optimiste
finalement optimiste pour la majorité
des revendications je sais pas mais
on demande surtout à ce qui est vraiment
une composition de notre pitié qu'on
crie d'une filière sapeurs-pompiers
sexuellement on est fonctionnaire
territoriaux mais on n'est pas
réellement un métier à part c'est pour
ça qu'on a des difficultés à faire
connaître notre métier justement on
avait vu c'est cette friction qu'il a eu
tous alors on les voit souvent dans les
manifestations des gilets jaunes ou avec
des syndicats est ce que finalement
c'est pas un cri de colère de la part
des des sapeurs pompiers
mais c'est ça c'est laura le ras le bol
qui s'exprime alors forcément avec des
échauffourées un petit peu avec les
forces de l'ordre et le fait qu'ils
aient cette confrontation avec la police
et pompiers ce que c'est pas paradoxal
oui un petit peu paradoxal après là pour
les stars la situation reste on va dire
à distance il faudrait pas que c'est un
bienne a du corps encore là où par
contre assad mais très compliqué et pour
les la police avec l'image de la police
et puis d'autres si on n'est pas venu là
non plus pour se battre quoi donc le
mouvement ils restent mobilisés c'est ça
oui tout à fait oui donc 20%
il est toujours là on est toujours
mobilisé on attend justement les retours
de cette réunion pour voir un petit peu
si on peut regagner non mais oh
très bien merci beaucoup à vous pour ce
témoignage grégory vous l'avez entendu
on va essayer de se rapprocher un petit
peu de deux pourvois essayer de voir un
petit peu ce qui se passe alors vous le
voyez là il y à prendre juste devant
cette barricade alors qu il y a quelques
mythes et a été a été noire de monde
et là vous le voyez il ya ces ces tirs
de gaz lacrymogènes et de tirs de gaz
lacrymogène pardon qui ont été lancées
par les forces de l'ordre pour essayer
tant bien que mal de disperser disperser
les manifestants les sapeurs pompiers à
l'origine on l'a vu il ya eu un point de
tension assez intense tout à l'heure
entre les forces de l'ordre et ses
pompiers une confrontation assez
impressionnant puisqu'il y avait cette
barricade qui est juste derrière moi et
derrière cette barricade il ya les
canaux où il ya les forces de l'ordre
elle a été bousculée permettant à
certains pompiers d'y accéder puis elle
a été refermé les ont rapidement repris
le dessus vous le voyez ici avec des
manifestants des sapeurs pompiers qui
continue d'essayer de s'en approcher un
peu plus donc l'ambiance ici en elle
elle varie en fait ça peut aller très
bien comme
après l'ambiance peu à peu se tendre en
tout la grèce ici pour la dispersion n'a
pas encore commencé certains veulent
aller à bastille d'autres veulent aller
sur d'autres endroits pour continuer ce
[Applaudissements]
qu'on entend dans leur cri de colère
merci mon âme ou dès lors en direct de
la place de la nation non loin donc de
quark de vincennes où il ya donc depuis
tout à l'heure des départs pont qui sont
entreposés pour éviter que les pompiers
nay sur le boulevard périphérique
parisien
même si certains d'entre eux ont pu s'y
rendre tout à l'heure selon la
préfecture de police de paris
l'intervention immédiate des forces de
l'ordre et celle ci a permis de relancer
la circulation dans les deux sens on
aperçoit toujours ces images étaient par
contre de ces barrières anti-émeute que
des pompiers tentent de forcer
je me permets de vous remercier aurélien
et qu'ils ont d'être revenue sur ce
plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du syndicat sud dans le
pas de calais vous devez nous quitter et
forcément vous avez un train d'apprendre
droit pour rentrer d'un bus à prendre
pour pouvoir renverser soudan dans le
nord de la france merci beaucoup
toujours présent sur ce plateau sur ce
plateau
jean-pierre colombiès porte parole de
l'ue béni l'union des policiers
nationaux indépendants si un commandant
de police la nuit est en train de tomber
progressivement sur paris la soirée
selon bout elle peut prendre quelle
forme on a entendu mon âme ou dès lors
dire tantôt il ya des tensions tantôt
c'est un petit peu plus calme là a
priori on assiste à un calme précaire
je ne pense pas que ça s'éternisera pas
c'est un avis totalement subjectif je
suis pas dans la tête des organisateurs
de la manifestation la façon des
pompiers donc on n'est pas face à des
irresponsables on est face à des gens
qui ont exprimé leur colère qui ont
exprimé leurs revendications par la voix
de leur représentant et je vois pas
comment ça pourrait mal se terminer
ce que je vois ce que j'imagine ce que
j'espère c'est que tout simplement tout
le monde retourne le plus tranquillement
du monde vers leur moyen de transport et
et regagnent leur région d'origine
on n'est pas face à des gens qui ont une
volonté de déstabiliser la société
on est face à des gens qui ont pour
ambition pour volonté de se faire
entendre comme beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs
comme je le répète les hospitaliers ou
même les policiers lorsqu'ils ont à
manifester faut pas l'oublier
donc il n'ya pas de raison pour que ça
tourner à l'émeute ou à les gérer des
confrontations comparable avec ce que
l'on connaît avec les black blocks
on a aperçu tout au long de cette
journée
certains moments de tension je vous
propose de les revivre en images
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
voilà pour certaines images fortes
d'aujourd'hui il y a eu des tensions
notamment en début de cortège 200 à 300
manifestants ont fait scission pour
partir en
cortège sauvage pour partir sur un
itinéraire non déclarée au final les
pompiers qui sont donc arrivées du côté
de la place de la nation
avec un siège face à des barricades
anti-émeutes départ pont comment les
appels pour
éviter que les pompiers
nice urnes var périphériques au delà de
la porte de vincennes
on aperçoit ces images un petit peu
clairsemés avec la nuit qui est donc en
train de de tomber du côté de paris mais
nous en ali sont toujours présents sur
place à commencer par guimard aussi guy
main on a assisté tout à l'heure à des
scènes de violence
où en est-on désormais ce qu'on assiste
à un calme précaire normalement la
dispersion est prévue aux alentours de
18h en est il exactement
aucun comme vous l'avez dit oui un calme
précaire dont on ne sait pas combien de
temps il pourrait durer pour l'instant
les barricades ont été réinstallés pour
l'instant les pompiers ne re ne
recommence pas en tout cas à tenter de
les deux les forces et ça a été le cas
de plusieurs reprises vous l'avez bien
vous l'avez bien vu sur les images qui
ont été diffusées à plusieurs reprises
les pompiers ont tenté de forcer les
barricades et la réponse des forces de
l'ordre était immédiate canon a eu de
très très très nombreuses grenades
lacrymogènes des grenades de
désencerclement c'est pour ça qu'il
était très difficile en réalité pour les
pompiers comme pour nous d'ailleurs de
rester à côté de ces périodes de ces
barricades puisqu'il fallait sans cesse
reflux est tenté de revenir dès de très
nombreuses grenades lacrymogènes qui ont
été qui ont été tirés plusieurs pompiers
blessés des civils également blessé
puisque on a vu des personnes en civil
être évacués parfois être
évacué à la vers l'arrière du cortège
donc un peu plus loin sur le cours de
vincennes
parfois dans des dans des halls
d'immeuble plusieurs ont été blessés aux
gens vous entendez les pétards qui
continuent à être a explosé pas très
loin donc parés pour l'instant écouter
la situation est en suspens un calme
comme vous l'avez dit précaires un calme
qui pourrait ne pas durer
tout dépend en réalité des annonces qui
devraient qui vont qui vont qui vont
suivre tout dépend de l'état des
pompiers de leur état de fatigue de leur
motivation tout dépend de la gestion de
cette manifestation par les forces de
l'ordre que se passera-t-il si à l'heure
dite la manifestation 10 mars pas
immédiatement est ce que les policiers
l'ont vont charger comme ils l'ont déjà
fait les questions sont toujours là et
on attend encore une fois que cette
manifestation se termine dans le calme
ou pas merci guimard si en direct donc
de la place de la nation alors que la
préfecture de police de paris annonce à
l'instant l'interpellation de deux
manifestants sur le cours de vincennes
des manifestants violents je cite
prenant à partie les forces de l'ordre
comment est-ce que vous analysez ce
chiffre cette information jean pierre
colombiès deux personnes interpellées
aujourd'hui une crise c'est un chiffre
infinitésimale groupe sifac tout dépend
de ce que ces personnes dont on fait si
elles ont commis des délits
c'est normal que cet été interpellé mais
enfin on est dedans on est dans des
chiffres qui sont plus anecdotiques que
révélateur ce qui est intriguant c'est
que de plus en plus les jours se suivent
et se ressemblent j'aurais pas qu'on en
est à une manifestation par jour mais
pas loin on en est et cadets samedi
maintenant ça se démultiplient une
colère une colère de fond une colère
sociale
j'espère que le ministère de l'intérieur
enfin je ne doute pas une seule seconde
que le ministère de l'intérieur
regardent les mêmes images que nous faut
espérer qu'ils en tirent sur tout les
bonnes conclusions ça par contre j'en
doute parce que c'est pas possible on
peut pas on ne peut pas accepter que le
rapport entre ceux qui gouvernent et
ceux qui peuplent un pays se limitent à
des confrontations hebdomadaire ou
quotidienne se faire quelque chose qui
dépasse un petit peu lente en demandant
ce qui se passe dans dans ce pays est
une vraie interrogation peut avoir sur
le sujet je n'aurais pas j'insiste la
police n'est pas systématiquement là
comme porte parole du gouvernement
parler du ministère de l'intérieur
sachez que le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner à poster un tweet il
ya 32 minutes
mais ce n'était pas sur ce qui se passe
actuellement à paris alors qu'on voit
certains manifestants masqués pour se
protéger un des sites des basques
professeur vince et pas des masques
voilà donc je disais un tweet il ya
trente deux minutes mais pour le retour
aux 90 km/heure et non à propos donc de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
évidemment on attend très certainement
une déclaration officielle de la part du
ministre de l'intérieur dans dans les
heures à venir
peut-être peut-être je sais pas si vous
en avez la certitude
bonjour je propose à quatre je me sens
pas certain du tout j'en arrive presque
à redouter des prises de paroles ou des
commentaires hasardeuse sur les
événements sociaux comme cela j'ai
entendu comme vous
commentaires du président de la
confédération des métiers de l'it et de
sapeurs-pompiers qui en fait fait une
annonce qui est un petit peu entre deux
puisqu'il fait état de promesses écrites
mais ne m'ont encore absolument certaine
donc avec toujours la porte ouverte à
une nouvelle mobilisation dans l'avenir
je sais pas si aujourd'hui à une
priorité absolue par un commentaire sur
les 90 km heure je pas certain
d'ailleurs c'était sujets polémiques
sachant qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
concertation vraiment très élargie au
niveau des territoires donc je sais pas
qu'est ce que le ministère de
l'intérieur l'intention de faire je
serai bien que de savoir pour les quarts
en le voir sur ces images de nombreuses
personnes qui sont donc venus sur paris
pour manifester plusieurs milliers de
pompiers pour dénoncer le manque
d'effectifs et de reconnaissance de leur
profession
répertorier leurs revendications une
revalorisation de la prime du feu ils
demandent 28 % du salaire de base contre
19% actuellement pour être à hauteur des
primes de risque accordés aux policiers
aux gendarmes les pompiers demandent
également le maintien de leurs effectifs
la garantie du maintien de leur système
de retraite actuel c'est une meilleure
protection face aux agressions dont le
nombre augmente chaque année
qu'est ce qui se passe là en train un
pompier à une personne des forces de
l'ordre qui situe juste derrière il ya
une frontière qui est physique mais on
voit comme des discussions ne vous
échappera pas que des revendications des
pompiers ressemble étrangement à celle
que les syndicats de police font depuis
des mois reconnaissance du métier
reconnaissance de la dangerosité des
forces républicaines les forces
régaliennes exactement on en revient au
même mais au même débat autour c'est le
débat le débat sur la défense du service
public et la qualité du service public
quand les pompiers réclament avoir des
effectifs en hauteur avec la police
réclament la même chose c'est pas
simplement par confort d'ailleurs c'est
pas un gros mot non plus de travailler
dans le confort
elle demande simplement d'être en
capacité d'exercer les missions que
l'état leur a un signe dans nos caves
d'une philosophie républicaine alors
soit on va dans cette lignée on accorde
effectivement s'interroge se pose le
problème de savoir si ces services tard
les moyens d'exercer leurs missions
régaliennes
soit on considère qu'elles n'ont pas
avec les avoir ça veut dire qu'on a une
autre philosophie
en ce qui concerne la sécurité ou la
santé de ce pays c'est tout le débat est
là
est-ce que
les primes doivent être équivalente ou
pas mais je pense qu'andy des jours où
il ne fut pas délégué syndical je suis
quand même l'intersyndicale mais la
réflexion de base me conduirait à le
faire puisque on s'est servi salle
dépendent tous de la fonction publique
la vraie question qui se pose est ce
qu'il y a derrière tout ça dès qu'elle
est l'arrière pensée qui est derrière
des pouvoirs vous avez raison de
souligner ses parts à un pouvoir mais
des pouvoirs qui ont laissé pourrir une
situation qui fait qu'aujourd'hui des
états des institutions tout entière
n'ont plus les moyens de fonctionner je
pense aux services de santé dans
l'éducation jean paré moi je suis moins
vous informer sur ce secteur mais vous
entendez les pompiers réclament
exactement la même chose que les
services de police
allez vous promener dans les
commissariats de france et de navarre et
vous y constaterez partout la même chose
à savoir un manque d'effectif
considérable entre 30 et 50 % parfois
d'effectifs en moins des moyens
matériels qui sont à mourir de rire
emphatique sont grotesques des bâtiments
qui sont parfois hors usage enfin il ya
un moment donné faut savoir ce que l'on
veut quoi est-ce qu'on ne conserver que
le public est là je parle du public je
parle du citoyen je parle de
véritablement de ceux qui sont dans
l'attenté d'une réponse de l'état et
skin so véritablement est-ce qu'ils ont
véritablement l'outil de la fonction
publique qui lui mérite alors j'ai une
réponse assez la mienne a joué jeudi
n'ont pas cet outil parce
qu'actuellement les services de l'état
ont renoncé d'une certaine manière
exercer leurs missions
on revoit jean-pierre colombien salim
agendé
des vidéos des images de tout à l'heure
de cet après midi certaines des images
les plus impressionnantes et plus
violente si j'ose dire entre les forces
de l'ordre et les pompiers qui demandons
qu'on a compris une revalorisation
notamment de leurs primes de son ils
veulent également à la garantie du
maintien de leur système de retraite
actuel alors que demain il ya une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation à
l'appel de l'intersyndicale pour
demander le retrait du projet de loi de
la réforme des retraites alors que le
premier ministre edouard philippe s'est
exprimé aussi vous avez dans l'étude
d'impact un nombre considérable
d'informations et ce quatre jours donc
après la publication de milliers de
pages de cette analyse je cite encore
l'ensemble des données sur la table et
c'est tant mieux car nous n'avons pas
peur des débats voilà pour pour edwards
philippe concernant le projet de réforme
des retraites
je détiens pas la vérité absolue en
matière du débat des retraites
loin s'en faut mais quand j'entends dire
que la porte est ouverte pour les débats
mais oui mais y'a plus qu'à alors donc
je suspends dont toute tentative de
réforme et revenons enfin qu'il revienne
plus tôt aux se changer pour partie à
mai mais qu'il revienne une véritable
table des débats quant au maître qui
leur mettent véritablement le projet sur
la table et donc pas qui le propose au
parlement en l'état pour une validation
qui seront nécessaires je suis dans la
majorité
non mais enfin je sais pas on là je ne
comprends pas je pas porte-parole de
l'étape je pense je comprends pas du
tout qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire qu'est ce
qu'on veut on veut que ça continue on
veut que la majorité des concitoyens se
se révoltent caste ou je ne sais pas il
ya un vrai problème de dialogue ouvert
au débat c'est pas du tout conforme à ce
qu'on entend on prédisait des deux
assemblées syndicales en tous cas de la
plupart je suis pas non plus hier et cgt
ni la cgt ni iphone ni l'unsa ni
ailleurs d'ailleurs
voilà donc des images
impressionnante de violence aujourd'hui
on repart du côté de la porte de
vincennes du côté de la place de la
nation pour retrouver mon à amoud et
l'or au coeur donc de cette
manifestation des pompiers en colère mon
âme ou dès lors il ya des pompiers à vos
côtés j'espère que vous prothèse parce
que vous avez pris à priori un nouveau
projectile vous aviez déjà pris un jet
de pétards tout à l'heure vous avez
encore été touchées comment allez vous
oh oui exactement il ya eu plusieurs
tirs de gaz lacrymogènes et j'ai dû
recevoir quelque chose puisque j'étais à
quelques quelques centimètres
heureusement que les pompiers eux m'ont
aidé et m'ont secouru m'ont apporté un
liquide pour que j'y vois un peu plus
clair en tout cas là ça va un peu mieux
on est justement entouré de deux
pompiers qui sont ici et qui manifestent
depuis 14h sans relâche érection ils
sont en colère et depuis depuis 14h ce
cortège défile dans les rues de paris 2
place de la république jusqu'ici la
nation et vous l'avez vu sur les sur les
images il ya eu des frictions entre
entre les policiers et les pompiers
guèye cette barricade qui a été bousculé
par plusieurs
plusieurs pompiers beaucoup misé elle
est extrêmement symbolique cette
barricade et il ya eu des tirs de gaz
lacrymogène nombre de la par les forces
de l'ordre également des canons à eau de
sapeurs pompiers qui qui sont fatigués
qu'ils sont en colère ce sont leurs mots
il ya aujourd'hui cette réunion à 14
heures qui était sincère
mais une porte notamment concernant
cette fameuse prime du feu qui veut être
réévaluée à 28% en tout cas je vais
laisser la parole aux pompiers bonjour à
vous merci d'être avec nous pour est ce
que c'est important pour vous
aujourd'hui de manifester vous le faites
depuis juin 2019 alors c'est pour c'est
important de manifester déjà parce que
comme vous l'avez dit on aimerait avant
une rue à vallière revalorisation pardon
de la prime de feu donc à 28%
actuellement 1 19%
les collègues qui sont en face eux ont
la prime de feu afin d'avoir leurs
primes de métier à risque justement à
28%
bonjour pas pourquoi nous sapeurs
pompiers on est considéré nous on sait
qu'on a volé tap
on n'est pas un métier à risque donc
tout va être mis à la juste valeur au
même niveau que nos collègues en face et
avoir la même prime de feu donc à 28%
meilleur on n'est pas là que pour ça non
plus on est là également aussi pour les
retraites on essaye d'avoir aussi notre
avantage c'est de garder les cinq années
bonification tous les cinq ans gardé une
année en fait modifications pour notre
retraite parce qu'on a un métier qui est
difficile tous les jours on est
confronté de plus en plus déjà aux
agressions d'accord les interventions
offert
des années elle augmente les effectifs
diminuent donc les cas liés au manque de
reconnaissance voilà déjà fait de
reconnaissance a fait déjà des mois et
des mois qu'on le regrette pour ça et
plus les années passent plus les
interventions augmente par contre dans
les camions les effectifs diminuent
on part avec un pourquoi incendie à 6
bat en ce moment on n'est plus sûr du 4
une ambulance d'accord on est à 3
normalement dans une ambulance balader
fois on parlera d'eux donc là le service
public est en danger la population est
en danger et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
manifeste notre colère et on aimerait
aussi donc justement avoir lu rauba les
revalorisations pendant la prime de feu
pour nos retraites et aussi pour de
l'effectif justement vous parlez de la
pénibilité
nous nous en tant que qu'un division
c'est que le métier est extrêmement
difficile mais vous au quotidien
'cependant détective comment est ce que
vous faites c'est très simple on fait
comme on fait comme et data en france et
des carences quand je vous ai diola
l'ambulance au parra 3 on parlera de
pardon alors qu'on devrait être à 3 bah
ça c'est de la sécurité pour les
sapeurs-pompiers
on intervient et des répercussions aussi
sur les gens que vous allez voir comment
est-ce qu'on traite l'humain quand on
n'est pas assez nombreux
bah vous savez on intervient on a on a
fait ça je pense que là tous les
sapeurs-pompiers qui sont là à la basse
et une passion d'accord sauf que là au
fur et à mesure des années notre
avancement de carrière déjà il est
réduit et je pense que il ya un manque
de considération de l'état
vous voyez aujourd'hui la colère on est
en face on a tardé avec nos collègues
qui sont en face comment on peut voir ça
aujourd'hui qu'ont ces gaz et on soit
l'un contre l'autre alors qu'au final
dans la même galère parce que je sais
très bien que en face aux 600
sous-effectif c'est tout l'ensemble du
service public qui va pas en france
justement là quand il ya eu des
frictions avec les policiers alors que
beaucoup dit et c'est assez paradoxal qu
est ce qu est ce que vous avez ressenti
bac est ce que vous les jeudis c'est un
mal être général comment pas en arriver
là aujourd'hui en 2020 à voir les
sapeurs pompiers en face des cercles des
gendarmes devoir lutter parce que l'état
justement ne fait pas son boulot
si on en est là c'est pas par rapport à
eux en face ni à nous ça vient de là où
elle est à eux de prendre des mesures
c'est des années des années ça dure et
là bas vous voyez le ras-le-bol général
les sapeurs-pompiers pas vous le voyez
là sur qu'enfin je sais très bien que le
ras-le-bol chez eux c'est la même chose
et on a obligé d'en arriver là
aujourd'hui c'est pas normal
est ce que vous êtes optimiste
finalement de 2 pour le pour l'avenir
vous vous le voyez très bien vous saurez
si vous souhaitez c'est optimiste
aujourd'hui qu'entre en rire bah ouais
est ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui
d
pompiers avec le sourire honnêtement si
vous voyez aujourd'hui des gens qui
viennent vous se courir avec le sourire
moi aujourd'hui je n'ai pas vu donc
comment voulez vous que
on intervient dans de bonnes conditions
que les gens soient pris en charge dans
de bonnes conditions
quand vous voulez que le service public
en général tourner correctement c'est
impossible pour moi je suis pas
optimiste
après on sait jamais on verra bien ce
qui se faisait au collègue l'a dit à mon
goût il ya un manque de moyens que j'ai
bâtie sur votre travail finalement et
bien sûr il l'a dit mon collègue je peux
me répéter il l'a dit il ya un manque de
moyens et c'est tout c'est comme ça mais
bon comme tout le monde le sait ça ne se
répéter ça et pour la première fois
qu'on vient ici sur paris voilà comme
l'a dit mon collègue c'est les tops
venez d'où roubaix est d'accord et vous
pareil je suis en collection voilà
l'état intervient dans les quartiers
sensibles d'accord on atteint bien on
arrive bien dans des quartiers où j'ai
travaillé avec la police tu as quand on
a des points de rendez vous on est
obligé d'attendre
est ce que vous savez est-ce que vous
pensez que à ce stade là on en doit
arriver là on doit se protéger par
rapport à tout ça tout et civilité que
ce soit des crachats des injures du
caillassage armand donné la laisse à
pompe ils en ont ras le bol
d'accord pour considérer un autre chose
diminue qu'on soit payé en conséquence
que notre réalisation que notre métier
soit considéré comme un métier à risque
que la prime qu'on a nous la prime de
feu soit au même niveau que les métiers
à risques d'accord et que la terre est
en sécurité pour nous d'accord et
surtout pour la population si on
intervient avec une ambulance à deux
personnes ne pourra pas faire le même
travail qu'à 3 donc la vie de la
population est vraiment en danger est là
faut vraiment vraiment vraiment signer
la sirène d'alarmé à l'état ça va pas si
on continue comme ça on va tout vous
voyez il ya beaucoup de collègues qui
sont en berne à août il y en a marre
comment ça se fait que
on s'engage étant jeune on se dit c'est
un métier les camions rouges c'est une
passion et que 10 ans après balleux
collègues il en a marre ils arrêtent les
sapeurs-pompiers franchement demandé aux
anciens il ya 20 ans si il dit un jour
ils disent eh ben j'ai quitté les
pompiers tout ça allait jamais de la vie
c'est que là ça fait cinq six ans même
plusieurs années il y en a marre
franchement il a vraiment vraiment
marquants merci beaucoup en tout cas
pour tout témoignage merci à vous vous
l'avez entendu grégory des
sapeurs-pompiers qui sont
sont en colère et qui en tout cas ne
lâcheront pas le combat et continuerons
à manifester ici c'est en tout cas ce
que la plupart des sapeurs pompiers nous
ont expliqué ici malgré les frictions
qu'il peut y avoir
ils vont continuer à manifester on va
essayer un petit peu d'avancé et de vous
montrer ce qui se passe ici derrière
nous une vanne ici en tout cas ça c'est
un petit peu vide et il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde la plupart me disaient
qu'ils attendent impatiemment de savoir
ce qu'il va en découler de ce
rendez-vous aujourd'hui avec le
gouvernement merci mon ami d'alors donc
en direct des rues de paris où on voit
des nuages de fumée de lacrymogène avec
la nuit qui est en train de tomber
ce sont des images assez confuse que
l'on voit
des scènes n'ont pas de aussi des scènes
de guérilla urbaine puisqu'on a vu comme
des tirs de gaz lacrymogènes de canons à
eau
il faut savoir raison garder jean-pierre
colombiès vous êtes toujours présent sur
sur ce plateau et je vais vous remercier
le mot de la fin où il me serait avoue
qu'il est il oui
d'abord on ne sait pas encore vraiment
pas on n'est pas encore dans une
configuration de guérilla urbaine comme
on l'a été sur des manifestations très
dur du mois de décembre notamment est
juste une négresse des scènes de
violence ouais enfin très modéré quand
même très très modéré juste une dernière
chose les paroles du pompier que vous
avez entendu je peux vous assurez vous
pourriez les entendre dans la bouche de
n'importe quel gardien de la paix de
france merci beaucoup jean-pierre
colombiès d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
porte parole de l'ue penny l'association
des unions des policiers nationaux
indépendants et vous êtes ancien
commandant de police
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions directes jean-pierre colombiès
la nuit est en train de tomber du côté
de paris rappelle les principaux
chiffres deux interpellations à paris
selon la préfecture de police de la
capitale
l'information tombée aux alentours de
17h30
plusieurs milliers de pompiers qui donc
défilent aujourd'hui pour dénoncer le
manque d'effectifs pour dénoncer le
manque de reconnaissance de leur
profession ils réclament des garanties
pour leur retraite ils réclament une
revalorisation de la prime de feu à 28 %
du salaire de base contre 10 9%
actuellement
tout cela pour être l'auteur des primes
de risque accordés aux policiers et aux
gendarmes
voilà donc pour les principales
revendications pour cette deuxième
journée de manifestation nationale un
des pompiers en quatre mois une
mobilisation qui a commencé au mois de
juin dernier à mobilisation très suivi
selon les syndicats
même si ce mouvement d'apprendre et de
perturbations majeures puisque les
pompiers sont astreints à un service
minimum
on tour partir du côté de la place de la
nation pour retrouver guillemin rosie la
nuit est en train de tomber la
dispersion était prévue pour 18h dans
huit minutes il sera 18 heures selon
vous la dispersion va avoir lieu
également aux é alors non il ya peu de
chance en tout cas du côté du cours de
vincennes là où étaient situés les
barricades oui en effet les pompiers ne
sont plus présents ils ont arrêté de
tenter de forcer les barricades de ce
côté là donc il n'ya plus en tout cas à
ce niveau-là d'affrontements avec les
forces de l'ordre maintenant reste à
savoir ce qui se passera du côté de la
place de la nation sur la place même
nous allons aller donc les conventions
nous nous dirigions jusqu'à jusqu'à
présent c'était une le bilan pour
l'instant de cette manifestation c'est
en tout cas plusieurs blessés en effet
vous l'avez dit
les annonces toujours pas d'annoncé du
côté de l'intersyndicale de là en fait
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner on sait que ce qui avait été
plus ou moins arrêtés au lieu des 28 %
demandés par les pompiers s'étaient 25%
mais sur trois ans et puis à la dir est
à la discrétion des heures donc des dix
partement et donc justement je suis avec
florent qui est pompier
florent merci de m est ce que c'est je
suppose que ça ne vous satisfait pas ce
qui était annoncé jusqu'à présent
donc il n'est pas allé 28% que vous
demandiez non pas du tout en fait moi je
suis un peu dégoûté de la réponse un
petit peu de l'autorité est justement
des policiers le problème en france
c'est que nous les sapeurs pompiers
professionnels on est très peu nombreux
ça fait depuis deux mois de juin qui ont
fait grève on s'était très peu entendre
on continue à faire les interventions
continuer à faire notre métier c'est
normal on peut pas s'arrêter de faire
des interventions du coup on a du mal à
s'entendre on ne demande pas grand chose
est-ce que factuellement est ce que les
personnes arrivent à comprendre que
sauvé une personne dans un feu à monthey
est ce qu'un pompier peut monter à la
grande échelle sauver une victime au
troisième étage vous 8e étage avec une
grande échelle à 62 ans est ce que c'est
possible - pourquoi c'est pas possible
donc il ya plusieurs revendications en
fait qu'ils sont valables et auquel on
revendique et donc je suis un peu déçu
justement de la réponse du ministère de
biens s'est passé pas définitif encore
on sait pas encore s'il y aurait quelque
chose vous pensez vous pensez que vous
pouvez l'obtenir encore ce statut et ses
28% de cette augmentation sur la prime
de feu à 28%
non je pense qu'il ya 25% c'est le
maximum nous on espère aller au delà des
25 %
on n'est pas reconnu comme métier risqué
ça je suis je suis vraiment dégoûté par
rapport à ça parce que d'autres
professions qui sont beaucoup plus flex
qui son portrait sans fard connues elles
sont reconnues comme métier à risques
alors que nous on n'est pas reconnue en
commedia risques et moi je suis un peu
dégoûté justement par rapport à ça nous
note remet tous les jours mais notre vie
en jeu parce que les interventions sera
assez risqué au fur et à mesure des
années qui passent
et moi je suis un peu dégoûté de
de la réponse ministérielle et la
réponse de l'état parce que franchement
nous les pompiers ont fait rien de mal
on vient on manifeste on a manifesté que
deux fois dans l'année ont fait pompiers
ont fait grève depuis un mois de juin et
en fait on n'a aucune réponse et je
trouve ça déplorable la manifestation et
sans se disperser du coup dans quelques
minutes vous pensez que ça va encore
durer un moment jusqu'à ce qu'en fait
qu'il annonce définitive
nous on attend juste des annonces par
les intersyndicales
ce conte ce qu'on veut c'est aller
jusqu'au bout après on attend juste
vraiment les les annonces intersyndicale
et après on avisera en fonction des
annonces qu'on recevra dans les casernes
et auprès de nos collègues en fait merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir répondu à mes
questions on l'avait entendu il s'agit
encore d'attendre exactement quelle sera
la réponse du ministère de tutelle des
pompiers de savoir exactement ce à quoi
les pompiers auront droit finalement et
puis
et puis de savoir enfin comment est-ce
que cette manifestation va se terminer
nous allons aller sur la place de la
nation afin d'accompagner les pompiers
encore présent dans sept à cette
mobilisation
merci guimard aussi donc en direct de
paris de cette manifestation des
pompiers la deuxième manifestation
nationale en moins de quatre mois la
dernière c'était le 15 octobre dernier
selon les syndicats il y avait eu entre
sept et dix mille manifestants
elle avait été émaillée de quelques
tensions également aujourd'hui il ya eu
quelques tensions on a vu sur sur les
images même si désormais la nuit est en
train de tomber on aperçoit plutôt un
calme précaire du côté de la place de la
nation là on voit des images qui se sont
produites tout à l'heure dans la journée
sur ce plateau viennent d'arriver
deux pompiers professionnels jérémy
courtel bonjour et pierre ruiz vous êtes
tous les deux membres de la fédération
autonome des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels
on rappelle dans les sapeurs pompiers
professionnels il y en a 16 % sur les
deux cent quarante sept mille pompiers
en france 80% de volontaires et 4% de
militaires les militaires qui ne
manifestent pas aujourd'hui puisqu'ils
ne peuvent pas manifester
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau j'aimerais revenir avec vous sur
skype dit tout à l'heure et qui m'a
réussi
concernant donc les annonces de
christophe castaner qui ne sont pas
encore officiel mais le ministre de
l'intérieur
aurait donc reçu les partenaires sociaux
est donc cette annonce une augmentation
de 6 % de la prime du feu pour arriver à
25% actuellement ses 19 % du salaire de
base et la revendication ses 28% alors
25% est ce que c'est suffisant est ce
que ce n'est pas assez
comment est-ce que si c'est si c'est
avéré comment est-ce que vous accueilli
cette annonce car use alors nous
l'accueillons comme toute négociation
puisque rappelez vous on est en grève
depuis fin juin donc un combat qui est
long qui fastidieux autant difficile
pour les administrations que pour les
gens sur le terrain également le nos
collègues vous voyez aujourd'hui
manifester elle n'est pas en lien avec
ce que nous demandions mais aujourd'hui
nous allons sens et par respect par
l'engagement dégâts dans tout protocole
quand c'est me s'arrêter là aujourd'hui
s'arrêter là cette primaire à 200 % avec
les applications et les les
les engagements écrits qu'ils ont fait
aujourd'hui c'est à dire s'arrêter là
c'est à dire nous avions demandé une
prime a battu pour cent l'objectif de
cette prime là c'était de faire le lien
entre la 2 résister du métier de
sapeur-pompier qui est aujourd'hui nous
pas reconnu aujourd'hui les métiers qui
ont des régalien qui sont dangereux on
touche une prime de responsabilité
c'est à dire que vous avez obtenu
satisfaction que vous allez arrêter la
mobilisation on a honte
en europe on n'a pas obtenu satisfaction
à ce que nous voulions 28% aujourd'hui
on a obtenu 6 % d'augmentation ce qui
nous fait augmenter la prime à vannes ça
pour ça c'est déjà un premier pas et
vous comment est-ce que vous accueillez
jérémy courtel cette annonce qui devrait
être fait par décret normalement c'est
justement une modification du décret qui
va du coup paraître qui sera mise en
application au lendemain de la parution
de ce décret comment le prendre déjà
comme un premier pas kenyans qu'est mis
en avant par le ministre de l'intérieur
c'est sûr justement une prise en compte
de l'état actuel et surtout de la crise
qui peut être en lien avec la profession
aujourd'hui on le prend dans
l'acceptation mais pas dans le va pas
s'arrêter là en soit dans le dans les
échanges il ya une négociation qui va
continuer derrière mais déjà une
proposition du ministre à 25%
on l'apprend mais on va pas s'arrêter
dans les négociations à ce stade là
donc c'est l'information 25% pour cette
prime de feu une augmentation de 6 % on
le rappelle qu'elle n'a pas été augmenté
depuis 1990 d'ailleurs à l'époque
c'était 25 % que demandaient les
pompiers dans dans les années 90 c'est
l'une des revendications mais ce n'est
pas la seule revendication puisque vous
dénoncer le manque d'effectifs le manque
de reconnaissance de la profession pour
être là mais également des garanties
pour pour la retraite et une meilleure
protection face aux agressions puisque
les pompiers sont régulièrement victimes
d'agression il y en a plus en plus
chaque année
donc par rapport à toutes ces autres
revendications qu est ce que vous allez
faire pour ce qui est des agressions
encore une fois le métier de
sapeur-pompier le dernier maillon de la
chaîne sociale
il va être mise en difficulté puisque
c'est la faute du manque d'effectifs
chez nous mais également au sein de la
police c'est pour ça que nous faisant
agresser quand nous avons douze
intervenants sortait à certains milieux
où doivent être normalement sécurisée
par les forces de l'ordre ils ne le sont
pas comme nous intervenons sur des
conflits familiaux qui doivent être
normalement sécurisée par les forces de
l'ordre
il ne le sent pas donc oui cette
agression là ils sont constantes
aujourd'hui le ministre a proposé des
protocoles d'action qui était déjà en
place depuis le mois de juillet 2019
peut-être augmenter un peu ses actions
mais encore une fois le ce problème
c'est un problème régalien de manque
d'effectifs
ce soit aux hôpitaux les policiers les
pompiers
aujourd'hui on manque concrètement
d'effectifs dans ses missions là c'est
bien le la plus grosse problématique
elle vient de là on entendait tout à
l'heure nos collègues parlé en disant
qu'il n'avait pas le l'effectif
nécessaire dans les camions et c'est
bien ça le vrai problème il n'y a pas
suffisamment de pompiers dans les
terrains pour que les gens seront en
sécurité
on va partir pour feu dont s'étant gens
là ils le genre il sera présent mais il
n'y aura pas les six personnes jérémy
courtel dans un instant on va revoir les
images fortes de cette journée mais si
vous devez tirer un bilan de cette
journée de mobilisation avec du coup une
partie de vos revendications qui
qui est donc entendue quel bilan est ce
que vous tiriez de cette journée
aujourd'hui et deuxième question est ce
que demain vous allez continuer le
combat avec la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale dans un premier temps
le bilan de la journée elle est plutôt
satisfaisante
une délégation qui est de
l'intersyndicale qui a été reçu par le
ministre de l'intérieur avec lesquels
ils ont eu des échanges en parallèle en
à une manifestation qui s'est
relativement bien déroulée dans
l'ensemble malgré quelques des
échauffourées du club d'ailleurs avec
des pompiers qui ont tenté de deux
d'enfoncer un débat répond présente du
côté de la place de la nation boulevard
la porte de vincennes pour pour essayer
de passer sur le boulevard périphérique
certains sont allés sur le boulevard
périphérique donc il ya eu quand même eu
des dd on peut on peut le dire il ya eu
quelques heures justement c'était dans
la tente du retour de la délégation qui
était qu'ils étaient reçus
du coup dans la tente et certaines
certains collègues qui du coup perdre un
peu patience et dans la dans le face à
face avec les forces de l'ordre
des fois il peut justement y avoir avec
des éléments et vous condamner ces
images on voit bien sûr là parce que en
parle on en a eu d'autres personnes en
plateau qui disait condamner les images
mais les comprendre est-ce que
l'exaspération peut justifier la
violence alors déjà dans un premier
temps pour les condamnés il faudrait
qu'on soit juge donc non le n'est pas
maintenant essayer de les comprendre on
voit des gens qui sont justement au bout
deux cortèges qui sont menacés en soi
parce qu'on voit que la fin du de la rue
il ya des palissades sur les côtés on a
dû dire qu'on venait en plateau pour
qu'on puisse nous laisser porter sortir
de cette place là notre maintenant voilà
il ya peut-être un sentiment de de
massage au niveau de cette place là
après il ya du roi des canons à eau qui
sont en marche des fois qu'on est en
arrière de cortège comprend des gaz
lacrymogènes comprend des canons à eau
mais des fois un peu la tension est
montée un peu plus haut et puis on entre
dans un état d'esprit dans lequel on
n'était pas au début venu dans ces
conditions là donc je vous ai coupé par
rapport donc au bilan et par rapport à
demain contre la réforme des retraites
je voulais se terminer pour pour le
bilan déjà
en soi une des retours assez positif
surtout des engagements qui ont été
écrits jusqu'ici on n'avait que des
paroles qui avaient été mises en avant
jamais décrit là les premiers écrits ils
viennent d'être faits il ya un
communiqué qui vient d'être fait de la
part du ministre de l'intérieur qui nous
a été remis aux différentes délégations
et s'était créé votre public en parlant
le décret enfin ces 6 % et seront
effectifs qu'en pour un même temps là le
temps de que pour lui de se retourner
auprès de 200 milles de son ministère
pour qu'il puisse être écrit après le
délai normalement il doit être plutôt
rapide de l'engagement a été pris sur
les différentes revendications qui sont
elles à moyen et plus long terme c'est
que du coup il faut détendre
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales ou ajustements apportés des
du concret et surtout qu'on puisse être
entendu sur le devenir de notre
profession est sûre les tangentes qu'on
veut emprunter pour celui ci est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il ya une inflexion de
la part du gouvernement qui a entendu le
cri de colère des pompiers un pierre
ruiz il y à une infection au moins une
écoute il faut remercier aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des sapeurs pompiers de
france qui auront suivi le mouvement
depuis le départ depuis fin juin ainsi
que les sapeurs pompiers qui sont venus
manifester aujourd'hui donc il y a eu
une écoute mais surtout une révélation
du vrai malaise qu'il ya chez nous
encore une fois on est un métier de
passion donc pour que les sapeurs
pompiers soit dans la rue et qui vous
montent au secours parce que c'est un
peu ça les gens demandent aux secours ou
peu aux citoyens aux politiciens en
disant faites quelque chose on n'en peut
plus on n'en peut plus il n'y a pas
assez de personnel on n'est pas assez en
sécurité il ya une surcharge
opérationnel et aujourd'hui on a été
entendu dans cette surcharge de travail
par une augmentation de 6% c'est déjà un
pas qui est important et c'est surtout
le travail les représentants syndicaux
et des gars qui ont suivi dames ont la
manie aux excuses à la fatigue de la
journée là cette journée qui a donc
monopolisé beaucoup de personnel
je reviens sur la garantie du maintien
du système de retraite actuel voulue par
par les pompiers
demain qu'est ce que vous allez faire
est ce que vous allez manifester à
l'appel de l'intersyndicale nous allons
retourner en intersyndicale réfléchir à
ce sujet là encore une fois le sapeur
pompier toujours ce dernier maillon je
prends souvent cet exemple là mais cette
retraite quand ces gens m'ont est en
difficulté financière
ils vont pas appeler le médecin quand je
l'aurai 64 ans 65 ans j'aurai un
problème de santé
je vais donc faire le numéro de secours
et je vais me retrouver avec trois
sapeurs pompiers donc le bout du chemin
de ces diminutions pensions ce vecteur
social c'est encore une fois le
sapeur-pompier qui va répondre
donc ça sera l'une de nos argumentation
pour voir quelle direction nous allons
prendre
on l'a dit journée émaillée de deux
heures de violences je vous propose de
revivre les moments les plus marquants
de cette journée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et aujourd'hui on arrive à des
situations qui sont plutôt noble puisque
chaque service de l'état se décharge un
petit peu sur les sapeurs-pompiers et
les sapeurs pompiers aujourd'hui arrive
à saturation de personnels et de moyens
humains et matériels puisque
effectivement on arrive a pu assurer
toutes les interventions partout
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est là pour montrer notre
notre ras-le-bol le dégoût notre
incompréhension face à ces agressions on
est là pour avoir le soutien de la
population
le soutien de nos autorités
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc vous avez compris ce n'était
pas les meilleurs moments de cette
journée en tous les cas les moments les
plus marquants je veux dire de cette
journée mais plus tôt
le calendrier de ce qui s'est passé
depuis juin dernier et le début de la
grève des pompiers jusqu'à maintenant
pierre ruiz quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé depuis juin dernier jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous retenez je retiens
que le mouvement syndical fonctionne je
retiens que l'engagement des effectifs
fonctionne je retiens que je retiens je
dirais plutôt nous retenons c'est
vraiment un travail du collectif c est
un groupe syndical composé d'un groupe
d'hommes et de femmes qui ont décidé de
prendre le seul romand et d'aller
jusqu'au bout
ça c'est ce que je retiens encore une
fois que c'est l'engagement citoyen donc
par l'action syndicale fonctionne t
aujourd'hui sont encore une fois la
preuve vous dites l'action syndicale
fonctionne et manifestation fonctionne
jérémy courte elle est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il faut aller dans la rue ont
manifesté parfois violemment pour
obtenir réponse aux revendications on
voit ce qui s'était passé avec les gilet
jaune et les annonces en décembre 2019
2018 pardonnez moi de
du président emmanuel macron et qui
avait lancé 10 milliards ensuite il y
avait rajouté à des milliards
supplémentaires elle a aujourd'hui il ya
donc une réponse qui est qui a porté par
le gouvernement c'est qu'on va rentrer
en période électorale il va y avoir les
élections municipales c'est que du coup
il faut manifesté parfois violemment
pour se faire entendre dans la
particularité avec notre profession
c'est comme certaines autres lorsqu'on
est gréviste
lorsqu'on est en période de grève on est
désigné pour rester et pour maintenir
les effectifs en place pour assurer une
continuité des secours la seule façon
pour nous d'être visible auprès de la
population auprès des élus de proximité
ou autre c'est soit par de l'affichage
mais qui peut nous est sanctionné
derrière ou soit par un déplacement de
rue donc aujourd'hui pour les sapeurs
pompiers la manifestation est un vecteur
de communication et surtout un vecteur d
coûte car comme on le voit aujourd'hui
avec la présence des différents
collègues une écoute a été a été fait et
des revendications étaient écrites et on
sera vigilant sur la suite justement de
la tenue de ses promesses la wii à
intervenir sur les wii je voulais
intervenir sur le fait de de ses actions
sociales ont vraiment un rôle important
le fait que l'on se déplace sur le
terrain sa maman rôle important puisque
encore une fois on en parlait tout à
l'heure en venant ici avec le personnel
qui est venu nous chercher
il savait pas que nous étions en grève
ils ont ils le savaient mélissa ne
change rien quand on fait les 18 vous
êtes toujours là mais parce qu'il ya
évidemment le service d'astreinte et le
service minimum qui est là et donc ses
services minimums fait que les gens
quand ils font le quotidien le 18
ils vont avoir des moyens en place et je
me répète encore une fois aujourd'hui
ces moyens là ne sont pas à la hauteur
des besoins
nous avons encore sur l'ensemble des
départements de france des camions je
prends ce terme là qui arrivent sur les
lieux d'intervention mais qui ne sont
pas en nombre en personnel adéquat
donc je vais vous prendre rapidement un
mot une intervention j'ai pris en une
phrase d'un collègue à nous qu'ils
utilisent souvent une intervention c'est
un corps humain une tête deux bras deux
jambes
si je prends l'intervention il me manque
un bras eh ben je vais beaucoup moins
bien travaillé et simon manque un bras
une jambe
là je vais encore encore un peu moins à
travailler et c'est un peu ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est interventions
ont lieu les camions sans
en place mais ils sont tous plus ou
moins rempli la possibilité serait
donnée aux départements les finances
pour le faire les finances pour les
faire l'état a la possibilité
délibéré le pacte de stabilité sur les
mises en régaliennes les missions
régaliennes excusez moi et la libérer
des fonds pour embaucher des sapeurs
pompiers des policiers d un fermi toutes
ces choses là et voudrait possibilité
que l'êta a hâte de faire c'est juste
une histoire de courage politique dont
il décidé de descendre la qualité du
service d'urgence souvent qu il
simplement s'engager ou l'annoncé d'hier
en souhaite ne plus aller plus loin
faire le minimum du minimum il faudrait
avoir le courage de le dire je vous
coupe pierre ruiz puisqu'il ya une
déclaration officielle du ministre de
l'intérieur sur son compte twitter
christophe castaner il ya trois minutes
exactement qui écrit je cite je salue la
décision des syndicats de sapeurs
pompiers de mettre fin à la grève des
engagements clairs ont été pris
notamment sur la prime de feu c'est par
le dialogue
jamais par la violence que nous avançons
ensemble avec les collectivités locales
on l'évoquait tout à l'heure
l'augmentation de 6 % de la prime du feu
pour passer à 25%
donc là c'est ça va être désormais
officier dans tous les cas il ya cette
déclaration de christophe castaner
comment est-ce que vous accueillez ce
simple tweet il ya trois minutes alors
que tout à l'heure en était avec
d'autres personnes en plateau deux
syndicats de police ou des pompiers et
puis il y avait des tweets de la part de
la préfecture de police de paris
mais pas de déclaration officielle de
christophe castaner ce que selon vous il
a tardé à intervenir a parlé
officiellement tarder non puisque le
collègue sont sortis ils étaient un peu
moins un peu avant 18 heures aujourd'hui
il envoie un tweet sur les réseaux ça
fait quoi une dizaine de minutes 15
minutes
donc il a il a apporté une réponse c'est
à un nouveau mode de communication on va
vivre avec
donc c'est une première réponse qui
convient l'intersyndicale on a également
noué une pyramide hiérarchique
syndicales à respecter donc si l'on
décidé que mouvement devait s'arrêter
aujourd'hui on va en foot remonter sur
l'entité départementale pourrait
discuter échanger sur ces deux démarches
et encore une fois il faut remercier les
effectifs qui étaient sur le terrain et
les gens en grève depuis fin juin 2019
les effectifs parfois épuisés 1 par
leurs conditions de travail
présent lors de la mobilisation des des
pompiers donc par milliers aujourd'hui
on aperçoit des
des images ici marc compte aujourd'hui
je vous propose de revivre toutes les
images les plus marquantes
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
et
je
voilà donc des violences aujourd'hui des
heurts entre pompiers et forces de
l'ordre
la mobilisation qui est sur le point de
se terminer
la dispersion était prévue aux alentours
de 18 heures il ya eu donc l'annnonce de
christophe castaner sur les réseaux
sociaux je vous redis le tweet de
christophe castaner je salue la décision
des syndicats de sapeurs pompiers de
mettre fin à la grève donc grève
terminée les engagements clairs ont été
pris notamment sur la prime de feu donc
qui va augmenter de 6% pour arriver à
25% du salaire de base
je cite c'est par le dialogue jamais par
la violence que nous avançons ensemble
avec les collectivités locales voilà
donc pour le tweet officiel de
christophe castaner et sur les réseaux
sociaux les violences de cet après midi
ont fait réagir de nombreuses
personnalités politiques
florilège les pompiers dans la rue les
forces de l'ordre n'hésitent pas à leur
taper dessus
gaz lacrymogène à gogo il faut oser
faire grève et ne pas respecter
l'itinéraire ils dénoncent le manque
d'effectifs et de reconnaissance et
demandent des garanties pour leur
retraite guerre fratricide
selon le ministre lunn aise la police
aurait porté à bout de bras la
république dans la répression des
manifestations retraite
la macro ni en est là la police
matraquer pompiers frapper ainsi ce qui
sauve nos vies est indigne le régime
autoritaire macro nist défigure la
république crs posez vos casques et
matraques rebellez vous vous ne pouvez
être fiers d'impliquer ses ordres
absurdes à nouveau des images
terrifiantes de pompiers en colère
matraquer les français ont eu macron et
le cas au maquereau et le chaos
ces images sont désespérantes emmanuel
macron qui a réussi à jeter nos
policiers contre nos pompiers devraient
réfléchir à l'immense responsabilité qui
est la sienne dans la profonde des
unions de notre pays
les policiers tabassent les pompiers
institutions contre institutions la
macro nice et la division et le chaos
lorsqu'un pays voit descendre dans ses
rues pompiers hospitaliers enseignants
étudiants chercheurs avocats
l'orchestré de l'opéra de paris et tant
d'autres c'est bien que sa société
craque de toutes parts emmanuel macron
doit savoir
on n'est pas prêt de lâcher la faire
voilà donc beaucoup de réactions
politiques
suite à cette journée de colère des
pompiers aujourd'hui dans les rues de
paris plusieurs milliers de pompiers qui
ont défilé pour dénoncer leur manque
d'effectifs et de reconnaissance est
également demandé des garanties sur leur
retraite mais surtout une revalorisation
de la prime du feu pierre ruiz et jérémy
courtel vous êtes toujours présents sur
ce plateau comment est-ce que vous
réagissez vous aux violences qui ont
émaillé cette journée et pierre use
aujourd'hui la réagi de façon négative
parce que la violence ne peut pas être
toléré nous d'un côté nous réclamons une
espèce de justice en disant comment on
se fait agresser
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on voit les images
encore une fois ce sont des séquences
qu'est ce qui s'est passé juste avant qu
est ce qui s'est passé juste après on
peut pas trop le savoir ne m'en va pas
dire que la vie que la violence est
normal il y a la société jouit
aujourd'hui de plus en plus violente
il ya une exaspération de des personnels
et des fois certains éléments parce que
vous voyez bien dans les images que vous
montrer qu' il n'y a pas trois cents
personnes qui essaient de bousculer ce
grillage en a quelques-unes
donc il ya quelques éléments qui sont
vraiment au bout et qui par colère
viennent exprimer leur colère sur ces
barricades
c'est plus une image non la réunion
finalement entre c'était pendant la
réunion je pense que si aujourd'hui nous
avions des images ont peut-être en
direct un instant
étant donné que les informations des
jeunes halte et d'image en direct là je
pense que mes gars est en train de voir
ce que les gars sont très disciplinés et
aujourd'hui sur l'ordi de cesser ils
cesseront bel exemple en est là puisque
si la consigne était passé de quitter
les rangs ils vont quitter les rangs
peut-être l'année enfants nous avions
parlé quand on était venu il y avait
également ces gens habillés tout en noir
rappelez-vous et bien encore une fois
aujourd'hui nous avons fait la police
entre nous donc ces gens qui étaient là
qui se sont glissées dans le rang au
plus près et qui ont commencé à lever
nam a lancé des projectiles je peux vous
garantir qu'il ya eu quelques violences
ou quelques rappels à l'ordre de la part
de notre ca de nos sapeurs pompiers
envers ces gens qui étaient là qui était
pas du tout des sapeurs pompiers
donc il y avait des black blocks
aujourd'hui il y avait encore des
éléments en écarter
les black box était venu pour ma
dernière qui les en sortie de façon
assez dynamique pour qu'ils sortent très
vite des rangs vous étiez présent
également jérémy courtel pour confirmer
les propos de votre collègue pierre ruiz
tout à fait même des fois on était
justement dans l'avancée qui était du
coup rythmée par les cordons de crs qui
était donc du coup sur les côtés et en
avant pour limiter un peu le l'avancée
du cortège
donc pour la première ligne était sapeur
pompier on se faisait même des fois
embarqué contre les boucliers des forces
de l'ordre et on se retourne à envoyer
que c'était des gens qui étaient
dissimulés derrière des écharpes des
foulards qui étaient gantés ainsi de
suite vêtus de noir et qui du coup nous
poussait contre les boucliers donc avait
malgré tout un certain discernement de
la part de certains crs et certaines
forces mobiles qui était justement dans
le dans la vision de ce qui se passait
et qui justement mesuré pour la plupart
pas tous mais pour la plupart qu'on
mesurer la réponse apportée
vous disiez tout à l'heure on a aperçu
on le voit d'ailleurs sur ces images
difficile de quantifier un nombre de
pompiers tentaient de forcer les
barricades les parts ont ils n'étaient
pas forcément nombreux par rapport à
tous les pompiers qui ont manifesté ont
dit plusieurs milliers les chiffres ne
sont pas encore sorties ni de la part
des autorités ni la part des syndicats
le 15 octobre dernier selon les
syndicats 7 entre 7000 et dix mille
personnes selon vous aujourd'hui
si vous deviez sortir un chiffre puisque
vous étiez présent sur place combien
qu'est ce que vous diriez du prime abord
parce qu le sentiment des taux aussi
entouré que la dernière fois j'ai
vraiment le sentiment de corps une fois
le cortège est parti il y avait encore
du monde la république
et pourtant le cortège faisait déjà un
certain nombre qui était parti donc j'ai
eu ce sentiment d'avoir autant de gens
qui se sont déplacés avec les
les futures annonces officielles du du
ministère concernant donc ce terrain
d'entente si on peut dire ce consensus
qui a été trouvé concernant la prime de
feu s'il ya selon vous une volonté
politique sachant que le 15 mars il ya
le premier tour des élections
municipales il ya toujours un enjeu qui
qui peut être de près ou de loin
politique maintenant céder des
propositions et surtout des des avancées
et crypte qui ont été faites maintenant
la sortie de l'intersyndicale de ce
mouvement de grève qui est prêt qui a
été jusqu où décider qui sera effective
à partir du 1er février sera avec une
certaine vigilance
c'est pas parce que les écrits souvent
par être que les groupes de travail vont
continuer et surtout évolué dans le
travail de fond que on va se retirer
complètement de des discussions on
continuera à être vigilants sur la bonne
portée sur la bonne application des
différentes mesures qui vont être prises
et qui ont déjà été écrites
la prochaine échéance c'est qu'on sait
quoi
pierre lui eh bien il l'une des
problématiques et là c'est un cas
aujourd'hui ministère de l'intérieur
nous dit il faut augmenter la prime de
6%
est ce qu'il nous fait monter à 25% il
donne l'ordre au département de réaliser
la mission sauf que les départements
n'ont pas les sous donc maintenant il
faut commissaire l'intérieur ouvre des
enveloppes financières au département
pour qu'il puisse exécuter l'ordre il
suffit pas de donner l'ordre il faut
maintenant qu'il en donne les moyens
rappelez-vous le sapeur pompier lui il
est dans l'engagement ultime des fois
aux politiques de donner les moyens
donc aujourd'hui ministère de
l'intérieur a donné une proposition
écrite il a avancé ce chiffre de 6 %
nous allons nous retourner vers les
départements et nos présidents de
départements vont nous annoncer qu'ils
sont prêts à embaucher mille pompiers
sur leur donne des sous mais ils les ont
pas rappelez vous on a trois patrons
ministère de l'intérieur le préfet
nôtres et nos pêcheurs qui sont le
directeur départemental donc qui va
trouver les sous encore une fois c'est
pour ça que nous allons rester vigilants
dire au ministère de l'intérieur
maintenant faudrait peut-être rapporté
une enveloppe financière pour pouvoir
tenir ses engagements de 6%
donc la vigilance est de mise du côté
des pompiers
vous êtes pompiers présents sur ce
plateau avant vous on a eu également des
représentants de la police des forces de
l'anp je vous propose d'écouter
christophe crépin le porte parole du
syndicat france police policiers en
colère je sais qu'il y avait eu un
blessé léger du côté des pompiers
mais je vous le dire que mme asayama
parité syndicale france police policiers
en colère nous sommes avec les pompiers
qui ont des doléances qui nous sens pour
nous légitime à la sarre du fait que les
violences nous les avons toujours
dénoncé aujourd'hui les instructions de
la préfecture de police sont très
claires il faut vraiment qu'il n'y ait
vraiment pas de possibilité d'avoir deux
casses ou quoi que ce soit c'est la
raison pour laquelle cette manifestation
est encadrée d'une manière très serrée
les dérives dispositif policier
justement aujourd'hui comment quel est
le dispositif policier justement gg des
gendarmes mobiles gd des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité et aussi des
dispositifs de la préfecture de police
qui sont tout au long on avoue des deux
chiffres comme ça parce que en fait
c'est évolutif en fait on a des gens qui
sont tout le long de la manifestation
là on va arriver sur la fin de cortège
sur le fait qu'ils veuillent puis
laiteries sur le périphérique
je pense que c'est inconcevable
parce que qu'ils exposent eux mêmes leur
vie et ils s'exposent à des
complications assez conséquente
concernant leurs doléances pour nous
elles sont louables mais faut pas
oublier une chose pour vos
téléspectateurs c'est que en fait les
pompiers travaillent sous instruction du
ministère intérieur comme la police nous
on n'est pas du tout opposés au conflit
au contraire on apprécie beaucoup de
travailler main dans la main
et là aujourd'hui la préfecture de
police ou donne des instructions qui
sont très clairs et qu'ils sont
justement pas de ne pas de ne pas
laisser à la porte ouverte à quelques
les actions que ce soit voilà donc pour
les propos de christophe crépin tout à
l'heure le porte parole du syndicat
france police policiers en colère
concernant notamment le dispositif des
forces de l'ordre mise en place
aujourd'hui face à face aux pompiers
pour encadrer
pompier un peu plus véhément que les
autres on l'a vu notamment donc sur les
barricades pour tenter d'être enfoncée
il y avait un pompier qui a été blessé
ensuite on en a vu d'autres qui ont été
blessées est ce que vous avez des
chiffres sur le nombre de blessés
aujourd'hui n'a pas les chiffres mais ce
qu'on peut vous dire ce que quand il
parle que la manifestation était
encadrée je vais vous donner exactement
l'image faut vous imaginer le long du
cortège un policier tous les deux m tout
le long du cortège
tout le long du cortège il y avait à un
garde mobile ou un policier comment est
ce que vous vous sentiez en sécurité ou
menacés ou vous savez l'être humain dès
qu'il est confiné il est dans une
situation de stress
inconsciemment le confinement vous étiez
angoissé aujourd'hui lors de la
manifestation créée de langoat donc là
je vous répète on avait un double cordon
de crs de bernmobil je sais pas encore
parce que j'ai pas eu le temps de voir
leur tenue un double cordon en première
ligne avec un troisième corps dont
derrière qui nous empêcher d'avancer et
de chaque côté pour qu'on soit bien
clair de chaque côté il y avait un garde
mobile tous les deux m je sais pas si
vous voyez un peu l'image que ça peut
faire
et ça du début du cortège jusqu'à la fin
du cortège
donc ça a créé une tension et ce qui est
rigolo et le monsieur en parle très bien
ces liens que nous avons c'est à dire
que la ligne de 9 ans voulait avancer
donc casque et toutes les images qu'on
peut voir des fois et sur le côté
on est en train de discuter de
plaisanter de parler de nos retraites
avec la même personne qui un quart
d'heure après va se retrouver en face de
nous pour nous empêcher de passer
c'est vraiment cette image là tout en
oeuvre on a vu un avis un tweet tout à
l'heure des réactions politiques on a
notamment vu esther benbassa
europe ecologie les verts parlé de
guerre fratricide c'est ça
j'ai un des critères une guerre en soi
non peut-être que derrière les offres
qui sont donnés de encadrer la
manifestation sont appliqués à juste
titre maintenant une guerre non on n'a
rien contre eux il en soit rien contre
nous en me le respect justement des
ordres donnés de part et d'autre je
propose d'écouter l'un de vos collègues
étaient tout à l'heure au micro de mona
amoud et l'or au sujet des
revendications des points car quand les
premiers de france sur la présence
aujourd'hui la première application sera
tout d'abord comment beaucoup de
français qui ne peuvent justement n'être
pas la présence par rapport aux primes
au public
par rapport en retraite c'est à dire que
sapeur-pompier aujourd'hui ne peut pas
partir à 50 tonnes avant la rentrée at
c'est pas possible on a un métier qui
est pénible et difficile ont trahi la
nuit ont subi les agressions
voilà le métier se complique
la phrase se vend mal
aujourd'hui et on le roi dans plein de
profession mais pour parler de cette
manifestation sous tension des pompiers
tout à l'heure sur ce plateau aurélien
et qui est en secrétaire départemental
du syndicat sud
aux 10 du département du pas de calais
c'est difficile à dire je trouve pas
dans leur tête mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est quand même pas mal de
pompiers qui sont un peu à bout après
quand même plusieurs mois de grève et à
ce que ça fait de vouloir vers ya juste
les terriens justifiée parce que encore
une fois on a eu une manifestation et 14
le 15 octobre dernier s'est passé
exactement de la même manière ou place
nation on a été menacé et on ne pouvait
pas rejoindre nos bus où on s'est fait
gazer cherche pas d'excusé ou quoi que
ce soit il y en a qui sont plus gênés
avec d'autres certainement toujours est
il que depuis quand même le mois de juin
l'année dernière on sait emmener en
grève et que les réponses à cette grève
de la part du gouvernement on parle de
non violence physique sauf que il ya de
la violence psychologique qui fait par
le gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années sur les pompiers
si on a des avancées sur nos
revendications le mouvement s'arrêtera
et tout le monde repartira bon enfant je
veux dire il nous on n'est pas content
d'être là je dirais moi je préfère être
dans ma caserne dans ma maison avec ma
famille plutôt que de venir manifester
ainsi tout allait bien voilà donc
aurélien qui en l'un de vos confrères
qui étaient tout à l'heure sur sur ce
même plateau c'était concernant une
question par rapport aux violences
du côté de la porte de vincennes
comment est-ce que vous réagissez à ses
propos jérémy courtel après des propos
c'est justement le syndicat sud qui est
en dehors de l'intersyndicale néanmoins
qui est pas qui a participé depuis le
début au mouvement de grève en parallèle
avec le snspp qui lui par contre s'est
désengagé de la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui
prenant acte des paroles qui avait été
jusqu'ici été émise ou la position qu'on
a souhaité prendre c'est justement
d'aller jusqu'aux écrit et maintenant
qu'on a les écrits justement on va
pouvoir avec l'intersyndicale réfléchir
justement à la suite des négociations
qui vont du coup être en dehors d'un
mouvement la grève donc la suite des
négociations c'est évidemment les autres
revendications notamment le maintien des
effectifs le maintien de
du système de retraite une meilleure
protection face à face aux agressions
qu'est ce que vous attendez
ce que l'on attend la première action
c'est de répercuter ces 6 % dans chaque
département de france voir de quel côté
nous allons sortir les finances
ça c'est un vrai problème rappelez-vous
mystère l'intérieur a donné une
impulsion à d'une ligne directive n'a
pas donné les finances pour le faire
donc il va falloir maintenant que tous
les pompiers de france a et dans leur
département se bagarrer entre
parenthèses négocier pour obtenir
quelque chose d'équivalent
un monsieur je vous propose de revivre
cette journée avec les images fortes de
la deuxième manifestation des pompiers
en l'espace de quatre mois au niveau
national
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà donc les moments forts de cette
journée notamment en termes de violence
en terme de deux heures les
manifestations qui se succèdent depuis
de nombreuses semaines depuis de
nombreux mois il ya la grève contre la
réforme des retraites avec une nouvelle
mobilisation à demain une grève qui a
succédé au mouvement des gilets jaunes
qui perdure encore chaque chaque samedi
sur le front social d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui il ya eu des gilet jaune qui
était présent au sein du cortège on a
aperçu tout à l'heure aux alentours de
16 heures des figures emblématiques du
mouvement comme jérôme rodriguez ou
comme faouzi lellouche comment est-ce
que vous interprétez la venue de gilet
jaune pour soutenir vos revendications
pierre ruiz nous remercions l'ensemble
des citoyens qui viennent s'additionner
à cette manifestation
donc peut-être il y à déjà les jeunes
peut-être qu'il ya simplement des
citoyens
il y avait également des personnels des
samu de france
on a vu beaucoup de personnels du samu
on a vu également des infirmiers on
avait également des des gens habillés d
avec les tenues des hôpitaux
donc il n'y avait pas que les gilet
jaune y avait un peu tout le monde
encore une fois c'est un métier de
sapeur pompier est apprécié par la
population
donc les gens nous ont soutenus et sont
venus assister et marcher avec nous ont
parlé des violences tout à l'heure je
sais pas si vous avez eu sur la première
image on peut peut-être revenir il ya un
jeune homme avec un parapluie habillé
tout en noir qui vient bousculer la
barricade sais pas si vous n'avez pas eu
quelques instants bah ce monsieur là si
vous prenez le temps de regarder l'image
il est extrait par à sapeurs-pompiers
s'est pas encore une fois on a su
inviter marcher à côté des gens qui nous
soutiennent et on a su sortir les gens
qui n'étaient pas là pour était là pour
faire autre chose que manifester et vous
jérémy courtel la venue de gilet jaune
comme jérôme rodriguez ou faouzi
lellouche comment est-ce que vous
l'interprétez on interprète comme un
soutien justement à tout causé toute
revendication qui est portée que ce soit
par nous par d'autres institutions sur
d'autres journées de manifestations avec
les justement la reconnaissance de
manifestations et des rassemblements qui
peuvent se faire
puis quelques jours ou quelques mois on
voit justement des différentes personnes
qui vont sur les manifestations de l'ain
puis sur des manifestations de l'autre
on voit qu'il ya malgré tout un certain
soutien interprofessionnels
intergénérationnels et surtout sans
pourtant en soit dans le emprunt dans le
dans la revendication même porté par
cette manifestation
on va justement en soutien aux autres
dans le but justement qu'une invention
soit commune est une avancée puis cette
notable pour tous vous êtes on le
rappelle vous étiez en grève dans tous
les cas du recul le mois de juin dernier
se fait plus de sept mois que les
pompiers sont épuisés par leur condition
de travail présents lors de la
manifestation un pompier a témoigné à
notre micro des difficultés auxquelles
ils sont chaque jour confrontés
quand vous voyez que là on entre un gros
coup pour le repos de sécurité ou en fin
de compte si vous regardez on devra
travailler 12 heures par rapport à la
loi européenne
mais on applique les lois en fait en
fonte vertement comme ça les arrange et
c'est un problème en fait c'est à dire
que nous on n'est pas reconnu comme
métier à risque au niveau salaire on est
des fois payer moins cher qu'un carrie
peur que les joueurs et c'est ça qui on
n'a rien contre eux au contraire ils le
méritent leur salaire mais nous on est
prêt à risquer notre vie pour tout le
monde pour tout le monde même pour les
gens qui nous agressent quand on se fait
agresser dans la rue quand on se fait
agresser sur l'intervention si ces gens
là étaient en piste dans un peu on
serait même prêt à donner notre vie pour
et c'est ça le problème c'est qu'on vous
expliquer tout ça use mais le problème
c'est qu'on n'est pas entendue donc en
cherchant pas seulement à vancouver
un politique qui un jour commence à nous
défendre qui reconnaît ce spécialiste
qui nous freine en compte tous les
gouvernements successifs depuis des
années de suivre un peu plus de 30 ans
qui nous négligeons tête sauf qu'on nous
négligeons nous il néglige aussi la
population on avait pu empocher pompiers
volontaires donc c'était un moment et le
problème est vraiment grave quoi parce
que nous on est une minorité au niveau
conventionnel mais les pompiers
volontaires un pompier volontaire qui
commence sa carrière la première année
tous ces jours de congé qui soit dans le
privé ou dans le public il va les passer
en formation et rap avec sa famille donc
c'est très compliqué de recruter et à
savoir qu'avant un pompier volontaire
quand il rentrait rentrée pour qu'un
maintenant sans moyens entre cinq et
sept ans et on les forme est là on est
en train d'essayer de trouver une
solution par exemple nous prouvent
qu'ils ont des propositions pour
comprendre les pompiers au secourisme et
donc les cantines feront comme le coup
la formation est un peu plus cher pour
l'instant dix veulent modifier comme ça
mais on espère être entendue mais pour
l'instant tout le monde ne veut personne
nous écoute toi tu seras pas tant qu'on
n'aura pas eu gain de cause par rapport
à nos revendications donc l'emploi
statutaire supplémentaire de sapeurs
pompiers professionnels avec une
représentation de la plume de feu à 28%
pourquoi 28% pour qu'elles soient
justement égal à la police
on estime que notre métier c'est risqué
que les policiers malheureusement on le
voit tous les ans avec des collègues
décédés
nous estimons aussi que notre métier est
super a beaucoup plus de risques liés
aux cancers notamment aux fumées au
rythme de travail de 24 heures qui usent
santé
veut aussi le retrait du projet de loi
contre la retraite bien entendu je vous
laisse imaginer un pompier à 60 62 ans
qui doit intervenir sur un incendie et
secours à une personne vous forcément ça
risque d'être compliqué donc tout tous
ces deux revendications on lâchera pas
tant qu'on n'aura pas abouti
la problématique aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir de gouvernance donc on a le
ministre de l'intérieur donc qui renvoie
la balle à nos financeurs qui sont les
départements et les mairies qui eux
payent justement les 10 donc chacun se
renvoie ses responsabilités et ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a du mal à
aboutir en éducation
voilà donc pour ces diverses
interview ses divers témoignages de
pompiers comment est-ce que vous
accueillez les divers témoignages de vos
confrères qui parle d'un quotidien très
dur
le quotidien est difficile la
reconnaissance de l'état et fait souvent
à titre posthume les en tant que citoyen
je pense qu'ils sont touchés par le
métier que l'on fait par les actions que
nous faisons tout est une histoire de
financer ça qui est triste autour de ce
problème là tout est une histoire de
finances je prends souvent ce terme là
mais c'est malheureusement vrai oui on a
une recherche du travail comme par
exemple peut-être que je vais apprendre
des choses aujourd'hui sur notre charge
de travail on a 24 heures / no 24 heures
de garde et on est rénumérés que sur 17h
voire 18h sur cette période de 24 heures
il ya un volume d'heures sur lequel nous
sommes pas payés oui c'est particulier
le sapeur pompier travail sur 24 heures
quelques heures gratuitement parce que
encore une fois c'est un métier de
passion il ya très peu de métier je
pense qu'on doit être le seul à
travailler gratuitement
parce que c'est bien le cas toutes ces
années que l'on passe ces quelques
heures par garde au bout d'un certain
temps ça fait quelques années qu'on a
travaillé ce sans être rémunéré donc on
fait aussi nous une part de sacrifice en
disant veut bien quand une fois joué
notre autre jouer notre passion et vous
sur 24 heures on est payé que quelques
17 voire 18 heures sur certains
départements il nous faut du pompier
professionnel
aujourd'hui le pompier volontaire il en
parle le collègue qui est
professionnalisé
le pompier volontaire sur les grandes
villes n'est plus ni moins qu'un travail
en ans déclarer par l'état aujourd'hui
il ya des directives européennes qui
vont permettre de reconnaître ce
travailleur enfin il lui a porté des
droits en tant que sécurité et de santé
donc ce sont des choses qui évolue petit
à petit le système devra évoluer on le
rappelle on peut parler des chiffres il
y à 247 millions pieds en france 16%
sont un professionnel
comme vous ce qui est votre cas il ya
80% de pompier volontaire et donc 4 % de
pompiers militaires qui n'ont donc pas
manifester aujourd'hui avec leur statut
de militaire ils n'ont pas le droit mais
est ce que
jérémy courtel vous avez eu l'occasion
de discuter avec eux avant cette journée
de mobilisation et quelle est leur
ressenti ou même après suite aux
annonces du ministère de l'intérieur est
ce qu ils sont soulagés avec les sapeurs
pompiers de paris
oui elle se vantait de paris ils ont un
devoir de discrétion et de par le statut
de militaire un peu plus fort que le
nôtre c'est que du coup ils s'expriment
pas on les retrouve dans nos
départements bien souvent sur le biais
d'un statut de sapeurs pompiers
volontaires
après ils s'expriment pas parce que
derrière quand on rentre dans un système
de comme le leur militarisé on leur dit
que c'est comme ça et puis ça sera comme
ça ils n'ont pas la latitude de pouvoir
s'exprimer sur différentes conditions de
travail entre vous vous parlez souvent
en échange après bien souvent il ya des
divergences de positions justement par
le biais que nous on a la possibilité de
faire évoluer par une action par des
actions syndicales le statut militaire
lui du coup les laisse dans un cadre
donc on échange
bien souvent ils font un engagement avec
une certaine durée dans le cadre de
pompier de paris aux pompiers aux marins
pompiers de marseille est bien souvent
les retrouve par le biais d'une
passerelle ou parle différents passages
de concours dans nos rangs ensuite en
tant que professionnel mais ils sont
déjà dans les différentes villes de
france en tant que sapeur-pompier
volontaire donc on al'occasion oui et
d'échanger avec eux sur ses positions là
qu'ils comprennent maintenant c'est des
discussions qui sont parfois animés
c'est sur le principe qu'ils nous
comprennent mais derrière comme eux ne
peuvent pas en bénéficier ni quoi que ce
soit il ya une certaine certains
échanges qui sont intéressants aussi on
le rappelle un du coup elle les
principales informations de la journée
donc la fin de la grève salué par le
ministre de l'intérieur qui évoque des
engagements pris notamment sur la prime
de feu vous évoquiez tout à l'heure une
augmentation immédiate de 2 6% pour
arriver à 25 % puisque actuellement ses
19 % du salaire de base la revendication
de base était d'atteindre les 28%
donc concernant cette cette prime de feu
la mobilisation est terminée elle a été
aujourd'hui assez assez violente et eu
des heurts entre pompiers et forces de
l'ordre
si vous avez un mot de la fin puisqu'on
arrive bientôt à la fin de cette édition
qu'est ce que vous diriez pierre ruiz je
remercierai l'ensemble des personnels
engagés dans le mouvement depuis juin
l'ensemble des organisations qui se sont
déclarés dès le début du mouvement et je
remercierai l'ensemble des délégués des
syndicats qui ont tenu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui pour aller jusqu'au bout du
combat et je dirais aux autres
organisations qui encore une fois
utilisé la sueur et le travail des
autres d'avoir le minimum de discrétion
et de respect pour ne pas prendre alors
que loire ce travail là donc messieurs
il ya un minimum de courtoisie
il ne dit pas que vous avez gagné quoi
que ce soit parce que vous n'étiez pas
là
le mot de la fin il ya mon pour vous
jérémy courtel remerciements c'est aux
collègues justement qui sont investis
qui se mobilisent depuis le début du
mouvement jusqu'à aujourd'hui car sans
eux
aucune audience aucun rendez vous n'est
possible car c'est eux qui justement
porte des organisations syndicales et
qui permettent justement à leurs
représentants de s'exprimer en leur nom
et d'aboutir justement à des
négociations et des prises de position
comme celle d'aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur ce plateau d'ayrté france
jérémy courtel et pierre ruiz
je rappelle que vous êtes tous les deux
membres de la fédération autonome des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels
merci à vous les principaux titres de
cette journée cortège
sous tension cet après midi plusieurs
milliers de pompiers ont manifesté à
paris pour dénoncer le manque de moyens
et a exigé le maintien de leur système
de retraites après des heures parfois
impressionnants autres pompiers forces
de l'ordre christophe castaner salue la
décision des syndicats de mettre fin à
la grève le ministre de l'intérieur
évoque des engagements clairs près
notamment sur la pelouse de feu qui va
être augmenté de 6% pour atteindre donc
25 % du salaire de base
le plan de paix de donald trump pour le
moyen-orient a enfin été dévoilé le
président américain s'est exprimé à 18h
heure de paris il désigne jérusalem
comme la capitale indivisible d'israël
mais le locataire de la maison blanche
évoque également une capitale de l'état
palestinien à jérusalem est aux côtés de
donald trump qui parle de chance
historique pour les palestiniens le
premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou évoque le site une solution
réaliste à deux états un plan de paix de
80 pages contestée par les palestiniens
qui eux n'ont pas consulté n'ont pas été
consultées depuis fin 2017
ils ont menacé de se retirer des accords
d'oslo
à travers cette vision jérusalem restera
la capitale unifiée ce qui est très
important
israël et les états unis reconnaîtront
la souveraineté sur des territoires qui
dans ma vision font partie de l'état
d'israël voilà donc c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale consacrée à cette
manifestation des pompiers à paris dans
un instant retrouver votre émission
interdit d'interdire émission de débat
présenté par frédéric thalys à 19h et
puis ne manquez pas également
l'info avec stéphane et demi rue ce sera
à 20h ex en soirée à toutes et à tous
sur rt france
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur rt france pour ce
nouveau numéro du débrief du doc
aujourd'hui on débrief le documentaire
chiens de traîneaux l'incroyable course
pour en parler avec nous jean combes
azahari les mushers autrement dit
conducteurs de chiens de traîneau